まあなんとか役に立つようにお話をしますけど
であまり今はもう育児は関係ないという方々にとっては
あの まあそれなりに役に立つように
一般的な人間論として
両方まとめてしゃべりますので
どなたにでもまあ役に立てばありがたいことで
一番最初に言いたいことは
この我々 この人間にとって
ちょっとした誤解があるんですね
で まあちょっとした誤解がありまして
まあ人間というのは この
よく勉強できて ものすごく頭が良くて
それからすごいお金持ちで有名になってという目的が人生の目的だと
そういうふうに思っているんです
あまり子供のこと気にしないで話を聞いてください
で あの ちょっと真剣に聞かないと
すごいきめ細かいポイントなんですから
このすぐ頭から滑る可能性あります
これ一番最初に言うこのポイントはとても大事なんです
人間はどのように大きくなればいいかということ
そこら辺で我々は最初からもう直さなくちゃいけないことがあるんですね
普通の世の中では ものすごい金持ちだったらありがたいと
すごい有名な人だったら
ものこれほどありがたいことはないんだと
ものすごい頭のいい人だったら
これまたすごいありがたいと
そういうふうな考え方を持ってるんですね
それからこの  女性の場合はね
まあ立派なところにお嫁に行けば
まあこれはこれこそありがたいことやと
そういう目的があって
我々は育児に手を出しているんです
だから どんな母親でも
自分の子供を成長させて一人前にしたいという気持ちはもう誰でも同じだと思います
そこで問題は この成長した一人前の人間というのは何なのかということなんです
成功した人間って何なのかと
それで親の心の中でなんとなくまあ灼道というか
いくらかのイメージができちゃうんですね
そのイメージ自体がすごく曖昧で
親に聞いても あなたの子供はどういうふうに大人になればいいかと
はっきりわからないでしょ
ほとんどわかってないんです
どういうふうな人間になった方が良いかと
大体赤ちゃんの時だけこう言うんですね
まあ元気で明るくて まあそれなりに大きくなればいいやとかね
自由に好きなように この子はもう好きなように育ててあげるそうと
とは その小さい時 なぜあんなことを言うんですか？自分で歩くことさえもできませんだからね
子供には 何もできない時はそう言うんだけど
どんどんまたあの考え方がグルグルグル変わっちゃうんですね
グルグル変わっちゃう
そこでお隣に付き合ってるお母さんが
まあなんとか学校の方があれはすごい良い学校やと思ったら
やっぱり自分の子もその学校に入れたくなっちゃうんですね
私だったらもうなんとか店でしか私の子供に服を買えませんと言ったならば
自分もまたその店に行ってその服を買いたくなる
そうやっても うちの子はすごいピアノ上手ですねと
もうもう3歳からももうもう弾き始めたんだよって言ったら
やっぱりうちの子もピアノ習った方がいいんじゃないかなと
そうやってまあいい加減なことばっかり考えてるんですね
そんな親が1日4回ぐらい人生の目的が変わっちゃうと子供はどうですかね
その被害者が だって全部子供の子供にさせるものだから
この被害者たちのこともちょっと考えた方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますね
ですから この話が始まる前に
我々は一番最初に考えなくてはいけないことは
成功した人生って何なのかということなんです
そこは最初から決めて
そこから離れないならば
脱出しないならば 子供にもわかるんですね
私はこの道を歩めばいいんだと
これ  1 日 4回ぐらい人生の目的が変わると
朝は音楽家になり ピアニストになりなさいと言って
もう 6時になってくると
いえ 画家の方がいいんですよと言っちゃうと
まあどうにもならなくなっちゃうんですね
それでまず成功した人生って何なのかということを説明します
これ考えてみてください
もし自分の子供がオリンピックで金メダルを取ったりする
すごいありがたいことでしょう
楽しくてたまらない でも金メダルを取ったのはいいんだけど
それなりにお金も入って豊かになるのかもしれませんけど
有名にもなるかもしれませんだけど
その人にはもしその人気のある子の生き方
それに対応できなくて
朝から晩まで忙しくて
あっち呼ばれるわ こっち呼ばれるわ
そこで日本人 国民みんなとんでもない希望をつけておくわ
今度のオリンピックでも金メダルを取ってくださいとかね
そうするとものすごいきつい
あの 何て言いますか 訓練したりとかね
朝から晩までコーチに怒鳴られて
怒られてとかね で いろんなことをあっち行って練習するわ
こっち行って練習するわ
いろんな至る外国に行って練習するわとかね
1年一回でも 30 分ぐらいしか母にも親にも会えないとかね
そういう状態には必ずなる
そういうなった人が その人生になかなか対応できなくて
どんどん堕落するとするならば
例えばこそこそと麻薬に手を出す
あまりにも希望を捨ててつけてしまったんだから
あの体力を作るためのいろんなアストロイドというんですか
いろいろステロイドですね
そういう薬にまで手を出したりする
例えば 体がものすごい激痛するのに
いろんな鎮静剤やいろんな薬を飲みながら訓練したりする
それで人生は台無しになると
それで母親は父親には自分の子供のことを正直に喜べれますかね
いくらいくら人生台無しになっても
うちの子はオリンピック金メダル取ったんだから
それだけで十分やと言えますかね
いくら人生めちゃくちゃになったっても
まあそれはそれで構いませんと
言えますかね すぐ最近
なんか女優さんの女優さんの方がね
の息子がね  2回目にもまた麻薬使って捕まれたという話
ニュースで聞いて  それでもその母親から言えますかね
やっぱり それでも私は大変人気のある 1 流の
タレントさんだから 芸術家だから
女優さんだからいいんじゃないかと
人生は成功しているんだと
子育ては成功 成功しているんだということは言えますかと
だから わかりやすく言えばこういうことなんですね
自分の子供が億万長者になっても
人生むちゃくちゃだったら
子供がいい加減になるわ
もう奥さんがもう家にいないわとかね
顔も会ったことはないとかね
奥さんと で もうどこにいるか
息子があまりに忙しくてわからないとかね
そういう人生っていうのは幸せかと
ですから このよく覚えてほしいのは
この仏教はただ金持ちになったんだからありがたいと
頭が良くてえらくもうえらい学者になりましたと
だからそれで十分やということは絶対認めないことなんですね
時々立派な学者の方々いるんですね
朝から晩まで研究室に閉じこもられて
子供の顔さえも見たことがないと
それはちょっといい加減
まあ余計な言い方かもしれませんだけど
なかなかちょっと見るだけで
あるいは家に帰ると子供は寝ている
まだ家出ている まだ子供は寝ている
そういうことで 子供の顔でも見ないで
自分が仕事ばっかりやっていて
そういうことっていうのは人生だと言えますかね
だから この世の中にある価値観
全部捨てない限りは この問題は解決しないんですね
どうやって捨てるかというと
まず人間で生まれたんだから
楽に楽しく すごく幸福感を感じながら生きることこそが大事なんです
なんとかして生きてるんだっていうことは大したことじゃないんです
研究室からもうなかなかもう 2時間 30 分しかもう外へ出られないんだと
1 年中 まあ 1 日しか休みがないんだという人生は人生じゃないんです
自分の息子が総理大臣になったら
それはありがたいやと
総理大臣になったっても
もう 1時 30 分も寝る暇がもう 3 時間も寝る暇がないとかね
それでストレス溜まって病気になっても
もう心臓発作じゃなくて
脳麻痺もうあれになってますから
病気はもう脳出血で倒れてね
1 日 1 日 2 日で死んじゃいしまっちゃうとかね
そういう人生っていうのは幸せな人生かと
ですから 一番最初にそれを覚えておいてください
やっぱり気持ちよく 楽しく
気楽に余裕があって リラックスして笑いながら笑顔で死ぬまで生きていられることが
仏教は人間に言ってる
生きる間の目的なんです
もう一つ目的がありますけどね
一応生きている間は泣かないで
悔しがらないで生きてみなさいよと
泣きながら 神経質で震えながら
怯えながら えらい憎しみで
嫉妬で他人を憎しみながら生きていて
こんなありがたいんですかと
それはあまりにも無知的な
生き方なんですね ですから
私たちっていい 親として子供に言うべきことはこういうことなんですよ
あなたは音楽家になろうか
学者になろうか 科学者になろうか
政治家になろうか ただのサラリーマンになろうか
勝手にしなさいよと でも
人間として豊かで 心が広くて
憎しみ 悩み 苦しみがない
落ち着いている人間になりなさいと
どんな仕事をしたっても
そこら辺ですごく余裕があって
しっかりと自分の仕事を果たせるような人間になりなさいと
そこが親の仕事なんですね
だから 現代親たちがそれを忘れてしまっちゃって
子供を学者にしてやろうと思っちゃう
エンジニアにしてあげるぞと
医者にしてあげるぞと
そういうことをやろうとしているんですね
それはお肉屋さんに手術頼んだことと同じなんです
だってお肉屋さんもちゃんとさばいてるでしょ？動物
だからもう自分の盲腸でもなったら
もうそこら辺のお肉屋さんのところに行って
お願いします 私のこの盲腸を取ってくださいと
あんたは手慣れたものでしょうと
と頼むったらどうなるんですかね
だから大体親たちがそうやってとんでもないことをやろうとしているんです
だから親の仕事は ものすごく立派な人間を育てていることであって
誰かこの学者とかね まあ政治家とか
そういうもう音楽家とか
そういう人を育てることではありません
だから親の責任がすごく多いんですよ
なぜならば 親の教育はその子が死ぬまで
死ぬまで大事なものなんですね
だから どんな親も覚えておいてほしいことは
自分が教えることが 子供にしつけすることが
その子が死ぬまで役に立つ
この子の死ぬまで役に立つものですよと
学校に行って数学を勉強したっても
それは一時的なものなんです
たとえエンジニアになっても
まあ歳までもう退職するまでの仕事でしょうに
それでおじいちゃんになったところで
あんなもう工学の知識っていうのは全然役に立ちません
その時はゲートボールぐらい習った方が役に立ちますからね
ですから この我々が狙っ希望している
狙っているというか この人生の目的っていうのは本当にもう意味がないんですね
全く意味がないんです
で なぜかというと このこれは仕事をしている間だけ必要なもので
それからもう役に立ちませんだからね
ですから まず覚えてほしいことは
この親っていうのは死ぬまで子供に必要なことを教える
あの先生であることなんですね
良心にお釈迦様が使っているこういう言葉があります
それは一つの言葉なんですけど
2つに分けて書いたんですけど
読み方はプッバーチャリヤ
プッバーチャリヤ その言葉はよく覚えておいてください
お釈迦様の言葉ですからね
プッバーチャリヤ このプッ
あの言葉の分けて分析しちゃうと
これは言葉 2つですけど
それはプッダという言葉とアーチャリヤという言葉なんですね
プッダというと アーチャリヤという言葉は一つに書くんです
プッバーチャリヤという風に
で プッダというのはあの最初という意味なんですね
初めという意味なんですね
アーチャリヤっていうのは教師のこと
教師 先生 だから 両親は誰でしょうかといえば
最初の先生 教師なんです
マーターピテロプッバーチャリオティウッチャレというお釈迦様の言葉なんです
全部行全部書くと マーターピテロプッバーチャリオティウッチャレ
そこでプッバーチャリヤ
最初の先生 だから自分に子供が生まれてきたら
その両親 まず考えてほしいことは
まあこれから自分が先生になるんですね
これから 教師になるんです
それで自分が最初の教師
そこで自分が教える教えだけが死ぬまで役に立つ
学校に行ったら出会うのはもう最初の教師じゃないんです
ある専門だけ教える教師なんですね
それはもう一生役に立つということはないんです
たとえ学校で国語を勉強したっても
まあ年取ってからそれを忘れちゃっても
別にどうったことないんです
他の勉強なんかは忘れてももう大丈夫です
危険はないんです でも両親が教える勉強を忘れちゃったら
そこに確実に危険があるんです
まあそういうことで 両親にどれぐらい大変な責任があるかということは理解していただければありがたいと思います
そこで その同じ言葉を子供に対しても言うんです
自分の両親というのは
自分の最初の先生であると
ただ何だかんだもわがまま言って
もう欲しいものは何でももう奴隷みたいにあげる存在ではなくて
お母さんお父さんというのは先生であると
だからちょっと厳しいと
気をつけなくちゃあかんと
ということも子供は勉強しなくちゃいけない
これはとても大事な言葉なんです
そこでなぜこれ言ったんですかというと
我々は例えばこの幼稚園やら小学校に行ったところで
そこで最初に出会った先生がえらく機嫌が悪くて
親切 全くひとかけらも親切じゃなくて
もうもう何て言いますか
ちょっとしたことでも怒ったりする嫌な人だったら
その子供は一生学問というのは嫌になるでしょ
先生と言った途端 もうものすごく嫌になってくるんですね
私は実際にそういう人々を知っているんです
あの頭がいいんです 勉強もできる能力はよく見えるんです
でも勉強しない 途中で中退する
中学まで 中学も卒業しない
そういう中退した何人かの若者と付き合ってみたら
この人たちは結構頭がいいんです
すごい鋭い判断能力もあったんです
そこで私が聞いたんですね
何でお前らが学校に行かないんですかと
学校ぐらい卒業した方がもうなんとか便利でしょうと
言ったらもう言われたのは
もうもうなんとかなんとか
先生はこういうこういうことをしたんだと
自分がやってもないことがね
まあ好き勝手に自分だと思って調べようともしないで
もうさんざんもういろんなことを言われるんだと批判されるんだと
そこで他の人でも何かやっちゃったら
まず疑われるのは私のことやと
で なんでこいつはと思って学校に行くことをやめてしまったんだよと
そういうケース いくつか私が見ていたんだから
やっぱり先生がひどい先生だったら
これものすごい大変なことなんですね
それで一番大変なことは
最初の先生がいい加減な人だったら
いわゆる両親が あんまりもう責任も無責任な人で
いい加減な人だったら
どうなるんでしょうかと
その子供の人生っていうのは必ずしも不幸になってしまうんですね
それで世の中を見ると
親を殺す子供たちいるでしょうに
この子供に殺された場合は
よくそういうケース調べてみてください
ほとんどの場合は親がダメなんですね
全く当てにならない 賭け事にふけているわ
酒愛好であるとかね ろくに仕事をしないとか
あるいは子供にも何でも何だかんだも怒鳴るとか
そういう性格ができてない
遊び回ってるとか そうするともうとんでもないろくでもない親先生なんですね
それで子供に殺されちまっちゃう
我慢できないところで
それ なんでそういう悲しい出来事が起こるかというと
この最初の先生が自分の役目を果たしてないんだからなんです
それで この私が母親だ
私は父親だと思ったら
なんかうまくいかないところもあります
とこもあります ですから
子供が小さい子供がある両親
何を考えるべきかというと
もう母親父親どころじゃなくて
私はもう教師だと 教師だと思って
ちゃんと教師として子供に必要なしつけをした方がいいんじゃないかなと
そうすると教師っていうのはよく知ってるんです
これいたちごっこみたいなもので
子供は勉強したくない
教師はやっぱりそれでも教えてあげなくちゃいけないという遊び
ゲームなんですね 子供は逃げる
先生は追っていって なんとかして勉強させようとする
塾と違います 塾っていうのはこの世の中で一番不自然なところなんですね
あれは単なる店なんですね
教育を売って金儲かっていうのは店です
それはもう大したことない
普通の美容室 薬局 そういうところと全く同じなんです
我々は薬局に行ってカツ丼ちょうだいって言わないでしょ
薬局に行ったら薬ちょうだいと言うだけであって
薬局に行ってカツ丼ちょうだい
何やってるんですか？あんた店やってるんではないかという喧嘩しちゃうとあまり意味がないんです
だから塾っていうのはそんなもんで
もうそれほど大事なところじゃないんです
行く人はみんなもう教育を買うために行ってるんだから
そこで問題は起きません
でも本当の先生っていうのはもう大変な仕事なんです
この間もある塾の先生に聞いたんだけど
もう学校で教えることは大変苦しいんだと
でも塾はものすごい楽だと
なぜかというと 来る人々はもう決まってるんだと
勉強しなくちゃあかんと
だから教えて帰っちゃえばいいんですと
何ももう性格は云々とかね
行儀は云々とか そんなのは関係ない
服はなんでしょうか？とかね
髪型はどうしているんですか？とかね
そういうのは全然関係ない
どうでもいいんです こちらは教える
教えなかったら 勉強しなかったら向こうの損だけで
でも学校になるとそうじゃないんです
高校やら中学校だったら
子供たちはどうすれば勉強しないでさぼることできるかという
そればっかり考えている
先生も先生の責任があるんだから
どうすればこの子供たちが勉強するかっていうことは考えなくちゃいけない
それは先生の大変な仕事なんです
ですから 両親も同じ立場になって
子供は行儀よくご飯は食べたくない
例えば小さな子供っていうのは
もう箸なんかは使えないんです
だから手で握って食べる
食べたいんですね そこで左手でも食べる
右手でも食べる で 手がもうものすごく汚れているのに
また何か触ったりもする
そうやっても小さいんだから
もう何もそこからうまくできない
子供の立場から考えちゃうと
まあ手で食べるのはこんなに簡単なのに
なんで親が箸使いなさいとか言うんですかと
めんどくさいではないかと
なんで食べながら走ったら悪いんですかと
じゃあ子供はもしかするとおもちゃとかお人形とかあるんだったら
ご飯食べながらそれとも遊びたくなっちゃうでしょうね
まあご飯食べてる途中でも
他の気が他のものに行ったらすぐそうやっちゃう
で そこで親が先生として考えなくちゃいけないんですね
ただ怒ってダメですよなんとか言ったっても
なんでダメですか？と
子供はわからないんですね
なんで遊んで悪いんですかと
だからそこら辺はまあ先生としてどういう風に言ったら
その子はこれは理解してくれるかと
そこら辺だけ考えると
まあ立派な親にはなります
ですから この両親は一番最初に覚えてほしいことは
まあ自分たちがこのブッダチャリアであること
先生であること なんでそういうことを
またもう一つポイントがございます
どんな親でもよく考えることがありまして
子供っていうのは自分の何といいますか
財産だと 自分の所有物だと
思う傾向があるんです
あれも不自然です 子供と親の関係は動物見たらよくわかるんです
それとは別に何の変わりもないんです
その場合は動物から勉強した方がいいんです
動物はどのように子育てするんですかと
動物っていうのは立派な親で
きちんとすべて教えてあげるんですね
縄張りってどういうものかと
餌はどのように取るものかと
そういう全部教えてあげて
出て行けと 追い出すんです
どんな動物もそういうことをするんです
で 群れで生活する動物の場合も
もう追い出すんですね
自分の子供を追い出して群れの一員にしちゃうんです
一応群れの一員になってから
もう親子関係はないんです
全く一人前の扱いで甘えてあげることもしない
ですから 動物は子育てするときは
子供は自分の財産だと思って
一生子供を束縛されて奴隷にしようとはしないんです
ものすごく私に見えた一つの理由なんですけど
なぜ親と子がすごくトラブルを起こるかという起こすかというと
この親が子が自分の財産だと思っている
自分のもの 自分の所有物
私物やと思っている だから自分のものだから自分好きなようにすればいいと勘違いする
そこで人間っていうのはもう自由に生まれたものなんです
じゃあ皆様に違う質問をします
皆様方 自分の母親か父親かね
自分を奴隷にして 何でも命令したりして管理するんだったら
それがすごい気持ちいいんですかね
何一つも自由にさせない
全部親が決める 何か自分一人で何かやろうとしちゃったら
親がものすごく怒ってこれやめさせたりする
すべて親が言う通りにやらなくちゃいけないという羽目になったならば
それは気持ちいいんですかね
自分が結婚しても 親が来て
台所の中まで冷蔵庫の中まで
もう押入れの中まで全部調べて
なんでこういう風にあるんですか？なんでこういう風になるんですかとかね
こうしなさい こうしなさいと命令したり
会社に行こうとすると
またもう年取ってるおばあさんが
お母さんが来て あんたなんでその服着ているんですかと
ネクタイ変えなさいよとか
このシャツはダメですよと
そういう風に何でも言うと
会社にも電話かけてきて
あんたちゃんとしっかりやってるんでしょうかとかね
言っちゃうと あれ気持ちいいんですか？そこまでやっちゃうと
やっぱりもう親を殺したくなる気持ちはわかりますでしょうに
だから誰でも親を尊敬するんだけど
親の奴隷じゃないんです
だから自分の心に聞いてみてください
私のことを私の親が何だかんだも管理するならば
私はそれ好きですか？と
そう考えちゃうと これこそ世の中で一番嫌なものです
会社に行ったら いろんなことを命令するのはそれほど気持ち悪くはないんです
それは会社にいる間のことだから
これは人生はもうずっと親に管理されちゃうと
それこそ世の中で一番嫌なことなんです
どこかの暴力団体に入ったところで
もう何だかんだも命令されるのは
それはそれほど嫌じゃないんです
自分の気持ちで入ったんだから
そちらの仕切り間違ったら殺される可能性もあるんだから
で 仕切り聞いたら まあそれなりになんとかうまくいくだろうということがあるんだけど
それよりも 例えばマフィアみたいな
この暴力団に入って もう完璧に命令されるように動かなくちゃいけない
それでも人間はそれほど嫌がらないんです
でも それよりも嫌なのは両親が管理することなんです
ですから ものすごく覚えてほしいことが
自分の子供は決して自分の私物
所有物 財産ではないということ
自由な人間であると 自由にさせることが
自分の仕事やと それで子供小さい時からでも
やっぱり独立性に独立になりたくて頑張っているんですね
だから親はすごい大きい
親の心 それを見て こいつは一人で何でもやりたがってますけど
まだまだダメやと まだ何もできないんだと
とまあ楽しく思いながら
もうもうちょっとちょっとお手伝いをしてあげる
まあ例えばもう幼稚園に
あるいは小学校に行きたいんだけど
行かなくちゃあかんでしょうし
でもどこかで子どもはもうちょっと不安があったりする
その時はまあちょっとその不安をなくすようにしてあげる
まあまあ大丈夫やと みんな同じ年で
みんな同じことやっているんだからね
まあそれぐらいでちょっと安心させてあげて
自由にする 幼稚園に子供と一緒に朝早く行って
幼稚園が終わるまでじーっと見張っているというのはね
それはやがて殺される可能性あります
そういうところか もう大学まで連れて行くんだから
日本では だから もし私が会社があったならば
もういくら才能があっても
そういう人は雇えません
ゴミですからね 役に立ちません
自分で判断能力は何もしないんでしょうし
それからこの 2番目のポイントにももう言ってしまったんですけど
子供は所有物でない これは一人前の人間である
権利は平等である 社会人である
18歳に八つ当たりになるまでなるまでではなくて
生まれて自分でも何とか何とか喋ったり行動したりできた途端から
その瞬間から社会人なんですね
一応 2歳になってくると家族の中の社会人でしょう
３歳になってくると 幼稚園という大きな組織の中の社会人でしょうに
４歳  5歳になってくると
小学校という大きな組織の社会人でしょうに
じゃあ親にできますかね
それは 社会人にしてあげること
そこは親の仕事なんですね
それも仏教から見る あの
人間の見方なんです 私の何者でもありません
これは社会人であると
この子は一番立派なのは
この地球の一人の人間であるというふうに育てたならば
まあすごい人間になるだろうと思います
あなたが地球で生まれてきた
地球の存在であると だから地球のおかげで生きてくるんだから
地球人について 地球の生きている生命について
あなたには果たさなくちゃいけない仕事がいっぱいあるんだよと
というふうなことを教えてあげると
まあそれは一生役に立つんですね
そこをその 2つのポイントを覚えて
それからこのちょっとちょっと小さなポイントをいくつかお話しします
なんか疲れました この間
あの 家で小さな子供を見たんだけど
子供は寝ていたんだけど
で 別な家に行って そこでまあ
その子供を見たら お母さんがずっと子供のそばにいるんですね
見張ってるんです で ちょっと聞いた話は
子供が起きちゃったら機嫌が悪いんだから
まあできるだけ寝かせておくようにしているんですね
それでも子供は起きたんだけど
起きたら まあ子供は子供なりにいろいろまあ遊んだり
わがまま言ったりする
小さな子供だからね それで子供にはわからなかったんだけど
私は冗談で子供にこういうことを言ったんですね
もうあんたね いろいろお母さんに要求しても
お母さんはもう慣れてないんだと
子供育てることにはもう初めてやっていることだと
だから何だかんだと要求されてもできませんよと
それはまあ 子供にわかることじゃないんだけど
そこでこの まあ大人にちょっとした言葉を言っただけなんですね
で 子供っていうのは自分の母親
父親しか知りませんし
だから自分に対して完璧に接しなさいということ
要求が子供持ってるんです
おむつ替える時でも ご飯食べさせてあげる時でも
寝かしてあげる時でも
起こしてあげる時でも
何だかんでもきちんと自分の希望通りに完璧にやりなさいよと
子供はちゃんと要求する
でも不思議なこと 母親っていうのはもう経験ないんですよ
初めて生まれた子供だから
何も一つもわからないんですね
父親にしても もう 100人ぐらい子供育てた経験あると
経験者じゃないんでしょうに
例えば学校だったら 先生っていうのは特別訓練受けてるでしょ
教えること 世の中で親だけ何も訓練を受けてないんです
それなのにものすごい大事な仕事を
任されているんですね
仕事に 世の中で一番難しい仕事に
一人の生命を人間に仕立てること
だから世の中のおかしいということは
世の中で一番難しい仕事は
全くも経験ない人に いたとして任せていることなんです
それはよく覚えておいてください
自分たちには 子育てにはもう全然経験も訓練もないんだと
だから 暗闇で手探りながらやらなくちゃいけないことなんですね
だから これ大変なことなんです
それでどういうことかというと
父親と母親がすーっと自分に経験ないこと
常識にできないことをよく覚えて
徹底的に勉強しなくちゃいけないんですね
どこで勉強するかというと
自分の子供から勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
私は昔よく使った言葉がありまして
子供っていうのは大学ですと
いろんな科目がありまして
それぞれまたそれなりにえらい専門的な学部ですね
大学っていうのは 学校と違って
学校でもいろんなことを教えるんだけど
専門的じゃないんですね
だから子供っていうのも大学みたいなもんで
いろんなことを両親に教えているんですね
だから あの 私はこういうふうに解釈するんですね
子供は泣いたりすること
例えばすごい小さい子供だったらよく泣く
この泣くということは
親に一つの宿題 研究テーマを出しているんです
親はもうもうそういう経験
前なかったんだからわからない
なんで子供は泣いてるんでしょうかと
そこで これは自分に出された研究テーマだ
それまた現場で今すぐ発見しなくちゃいかないんだと
ですから もうたまに間違ってもいいんだから
間違いながらも なんで子供は泣いてるんでしょうかと
それは発見する 私が見たところで発見することじゃなくて
なんとかごまかす 子供が泣いちゃうと
何とかしてごまかして
もう泣かないようにする
まあそれもその場合によって悪くはないんだけど
いつでもごまかせばいいっていうことじゃないんです
ですから 子供は泣くということさえも自分に宿題出してるんです
それを発見する そうすると自分の勉強になる
これは例えば ３ヶ月間ぐらい
そうやって子供を観察しちゃうと
大体母親っていうのは泣いただけでわかるんですね
あれもお腹が空いてるんだ
あれは遊びたがってるんだとかね
あの 今はなんか暑すぎですよと
今はちょっと寒くて泣いてるんだよと
すぐわかるようになるんです
ただ泣き声だけで で そういう風に自分でこの
子供を大学にしてしまって研究する
そこをやっちゃうと 決してこの育児ヒステリーにはなりません
この育児ヒステリーという病気がありますね
あれは何ですか？と 子供は泣くわ泣くわ泣くわ泣くわ泣くわ
何やっても泣き止まない
それで嫌になってくるんですね
自分にも寝る暇もないし
そういうものすごく泣く子がちょっと大きくなってきても泣きはやめますけど
それからまたわがままで
あれこれこれこれ これが嫌
あれが嫌というものすごいわがままになっちゃうんです
その時ももう言葉を喋れるんだから
母親をもうカンカン怒ってヒステリーになるんですね
だから気持ちとしては子供を育てたいんだけど
どうもうまくいかない
それでぶったり殴ったり
あのあれ 何て言いますか
虐待したりする そこで虐待する母親たちの話をテレビで見ていたんだけど
自分の子供だからものすごく可愛いんだと
虐待は全然したくないんだと
それでも泣いたりわがまま言ったりすると
ついやってしまっちゃいますよと言って
自分のことも怖くなってくるんですね
その問題解決する方法っていうのは
子供っていうのはもうえらい大学で
ものすごい難しい研究課題を出しちゃうんですね
これをやりなさいと だから子供はもう生まれた時からものすごく泣く場合も
母親がなんとか泣きさえ
泣くことさえやんでくれればいいやという気持ちで抑えよう
抑えよう 抑えようとする
だからヒステリーが起こしちゃうんですね
ですから いろんな方法を試してみて
試してみたところで 子供はなんで泣くの？っていうことが見つかるんです
いろんな理由はあるんです
一番皆様にはそれほど問題ないと思いますけど
時々このホルモンのバランスがあまり良くなくて
親の食べ物やら生きる環境とか
それですごく胎児に影響を与えるんだから
ものすごい神経質に生まれる場合もあります
あまりにも神経質で 赤ちゃんが生まれる前からもうものすごいストレスの塊で生まれる時あります
ですから 子供にとってはすごくこれ我慢できないんですね
体がすごい小さい 心は大人と同じなんです
心のエネルギーが だから巨大な心のエネルギーでストレス溜まって
この小さな体の中で それはなんとか処理しなくちゃいけないでしょうし
そうするとものすごく泣いたりする
だから そこは一番大変な問題なんですけど
なんで生まれた瞬間からもうそれほどストレス溜まってるかと
それはやっぱり親がね
妊娠中の生き方やら食べた食べ物やら環境やら
そういういろんなものの影響もあります
だからこれかなりの研究課題なんです
子供が泣くということさえも
なんで泣くかということさえも
一人私が昔知っていた子供がいて
この 母親が日本人で父親が外国人なんですね
そこでこの子供は育てる環境では
この父親の方の人間がたくさん手を貸す
いろいろと子育てに でも子供は日本で育てるんだから
子供の心の中の文化はもう完璧に日本文化なんですね
ですね 小さい時だからしょうがないでしょうし
自分が完璧に日本の文化の中の人間なのに
自分にご飯を作ってくるおばあちゃんが違う文化で日本語も喋れない
そこで子供と遊ぶ時でも
ちょっと文化が違う 子供は何かわがままを要求したっても
対応のやり方が違う 日本的じゃない
それでものすごくその子にはストレスなんですね
ですね そこでこの外国のグループが全然全然それを理解しない
理解もできない 私はあの子もかなりの被害者やと
そこでこの日本の母親がもうほとんどいい加減で
それほど子育てには手を出せない
できるだけ手を引こうとする
でも子供が日本文化に文化的な育ち方がもう慣れたもので
それ要求しているんですね
そこである日こういうことを見たんだ
子供は泣くわ泣くわ もういくら抱っこしたっても
ものすごくもう嫌で嫌で
おじいさんにもおばあちゃんにももう誰にもできない
そこで そこら辺にいた全くも関係ない
その人々 誰かともわからない
ある日本のおばあさんが
全くも知らない人なんですけど
その子供を抱っこしたんです
すぐ泣き止んじゃったんです
だから考えてください
小さな子供っていうのは
全く知らない人に抱っこしたら
全然機嫌が悪いでしょうに
知らない人に抱っこしたっても
それは嫌でしょうに すぐ自分の親戚のところに飛んで行っちゃうでしょうに
やっぱりあの子は知らない日本のばあさんに抱っこしちゃったら
もう何のことなくもう泣き止めて
そういう風にもいろいろ子供にとっては問題があるんです
そこで私が理解したのは
やっぱりこれは文化の違いやと
子供は日本文化にもう小さいだから
この ２つの文化にまだ慣れるのは早いいきなり身に入った文化は受け取っちゃって
それは基準にしている
だから知らないおばあさんでも抱っこしちゃったら
日本語で喋ってくれるし
対応する言葉もそれなりに子供にふさわしい言葉でしょうし
それで落ち着いてしまったんですね
ですから この 子供を泣いたっていうことは
我々にとってはもう大学研究課題
そこを研究しなくちゃいけない
大勢の場合はすぐ発見できます
どうしても泣き止まない場合は
何か病院にでも連れて行って
体の状態はどうでしょうかとかね
そういうことを理解した方がいいんですね
もう一つ言いますけど
小さな子供たちもいる
お母さんたちが見えますから
自分の子供がずっと寝てるでしょ？大体寝ていたら目が覚めた瞬間で子供を見てください
この目が覚めた瞬間で
子供の態度がその子の基本的な性格なんです
そこで あ その子はどのように育てればいいかということを発見できます
だから この子供の性格がわからないんだ
わからないんだというのは
ちょっと寂しいことなんです
だから 子供は遊んでいる時やら
もうニコニコと笑って遊んでいる時なんかは性格見えません
すごく怒ってキャーキャーと泣いている時でも
あんまり性格は見えません
そこでじーっと寝ていて目が覚めるでしょうに
目が覚めた瞬間で自分一人なんですね
この一人で目が覚めたら子供はどんな対応をするかと
そこで子供の基本的な性格を見えますから
それからそこに合わせて
育てればいいんです  わかりやすい例で言えば
時々目が覚めた途端泣くんだけど
誰かがそばにそこら辺いるんだったら泣かない子がいるんですね
それは寂しがり屋ですね
一人でいたくない と すぐわかるんです
寂しがり屋だと そこでまた目が覚めたらすぐ泣く
泣いたところで母親が来て抱っこして
まあ慰めてあげない限りは泣き止めない
ある機嫌が悪いんですね
目が覚めたら それは結構
このわがままなんですね
激しい 赤ちゃんだから見えないだけなんですが
大人になったら大変激しい性格になります
そこを覚えておいてください
ああ この子はかなりわがままやと
それからまあ 目が覚めた途端
まあ何のことなくすぐ笑う
一人でも笑って遊ぶという子もいるんですね
それはあてまえで かなり明るい
それほど手がかからない子ですね
この子はすごく明るくて
それほど手がかからないと
そこでもちょっとした
それでもちょっとした引っ掛けがあるんです
時々子供がいるんですね
小さい時からもうやっぱり大人の機嫌を取ろうとする
よく笑ってあげる で もうもう誰を誰手を出しても
おばあちゃん手を出しても
おじいさん手を出しても
お父さん手を出しても
兄弟誰が手を出すも すぐもう抱っこさせてもらうと
そうやって まあみんなの機嫌を取る子もいます
これは赤ちゃんの時でもあります
その性格 それも大体目が覚めた瞬間でよくわかります
それも一つの性格なんですね
もしかすると そういう子が成功する可能性もあるし
まあ人の機嫌を取るんだからね
あれは悪く言っちゃえば
ちょっとずるいずる賢い人間になってしまう場合もあります
それは親の仕事をいい方向へ持っていくことは
たとえ このものすごいガガ強くて荒っぽい赤ちゃんであろうとも
まあそれは良くないことやということは
それからコツコツと教えてあげればいいことだからね
基本的な性格は何であろうとも
良い方向へ育てるのが親の仕事なんですね
そういう風にこの子供っていうのは
この大学だと思って接しちゃうと
まあ結構やりがいがあると思います
大変ですよ かなり自分の頭が鋭く回らないと
例えば言葉を喋るようになったら何でも聞くでしょ
あれは何？これは何？これは何ですか
これは何ですかとかね
何でも聞くんだけども
親が困るんですね こんなこと教えたってわかるわけないでしょうと
で そこら辺でも親に親の宿題ですよ
研究課題なんですね  2つあります
一つは 子供は別にあれを聞いてるんじゃないんです
ただ 初めて習った日本語の訓練してるだけ
単語を覚えなくちゃいけないし
ですから 何の何であろうとも
あれはなんで？と聞く
ご飯もう米を洗っていると
なんで洗っているんですかと
それはまあ来てないんだから綺麗にするためやと
じゃあなんで綺麗にするんですか？と
ついまたなんでか入ってくる
それぐらいは答えられますけどね
なんでスイッチ入れるんですか？とかね
なんで待ってるんですか？と
もう何でもなんでなんでとか
もうこれやりきれないぐらい聞くんですね
その場合もやっぱり一つは
子供は言葉を覚えてる段階があります
それ終わったらすぐ情報を獲得する段階に入るんですね
そこを覚えておいて 情報を獲得する段階になってくると
ちゃんと論理的に情報を与えて与えなくちゃいけないんです
ごまかしてはいけません
これ難しいんですよ だから大学だからしょうがないでしょうに
難しいんだからやめたっていうことはそんなにいきませんだから
だから一番悪いことに
子供が一番知りたがるのはね
自分がどうやって生まれてきたんですか？とかね
一番説明しにくいところなんですけど
子供はそれを先に知りたがるんですね
そう どうすればすればいいかと
どう説明すればいいかとわからなくなりますけどね
それももう自然な流れで
なぜならば 子供は自分の存在にもう気づいているんですね
だから親にすごくかわいがってもらって
すごく元気で生きている
そういう自分のように出てきたんでしょうかと
という自分に対する興味なんです
そこでこうのとりが持ってきたとかね
言ってもやっぱりね そう言わない方がいいんです
何のも根拠もない嘘 で
自分小さい時から小さい時
自分も何質問したんですけど
覚えているんだからね
で 言われたのはそこら辺から拾ってきたんだと
で まあそこら辺から拾ってきて
まあ一生懸命育てるんだと
ということで まだもうあまり泣いたりしてわがまま言うなよという感じなんですね
そういう聞いたらすごく悲しくなっちゃったんですね
結局は もうすごい小さいんだから
ただなんか嫌な気持ちが出たんだけど
どうしようもないんですね
もう言葉を喋れませんだから
まあ現代はね それほど問題も昔ですからね
いろいろ道徳世界っていうのは厳しい時代で
我々育てられちゃったんだからね
まあ今はそれほど問題はないんですけどね
でも 2番目の子には教えやすいんだけどね
1番目は難しいんですよ
ただ また逆に 1番目一番経験ないんだから
上の子を育てる場合はね
2番目の子が出てくると
やっぱりもう上の子にはね
まあお腹の中にもう一人子供がいるんだよっていうことは教えてあげることはできますけど
だからその質問は必ず来る
何のことなく本当のことを言っちゃえばいいんです
問題ないんです お腹の中でこういう風に
こういう風に出てきたんだよと
あまりわかりません 子供はそういうことを言っても
でも本当のことを言うと
なるほど 大変なことをやっていることぐらいは覚えておくんですね
寂しくはならないんです
ある子供が母親にこのキウイという果物ありますね
キウイフルーツという緑色のあまり美味しくない果物
美味しくないんだけど
体にいいんですけどね
あれはあのつる２つないと実りませんね
雄しべというかね 花がね
あの雌しべと言うんですか
それ別々なつるで花が咲くんですね
だから 実って欲しければ ２
つちゃんと育てないとできない
ある子供に私は何のことなくもう何でも聞くんだから
まあこれはこういう雄しべのつるで
これは雌しべが出るつるで
その２つ一緒になるんだから
いっぱい実が乗ってるんだよ
と言っただけで それでまあ良心で聞くんですね
なんでそういう風になって
私はもうあまりもう説明したくない状態でしたからね
なんで雄しべと雌しべがなければ実らないかと
果物が出てこないかと聞いたら
もう親には説明できなくて
そこで親がじゃあ私に聞いてくださいと
それで私は何のことなく
普通の学校で教えるような感じで
あの まあこういう風に受粉のことやらね
で そうやって別々なものを繋げたらもう実るんだよと言ったんですね
それで次の質問というのは
やっぱりもうなぜそういうふうにならなくちゃいけないんですか？と言ったら
まあ世の中はどこでも見なさいよ
鳥でもみんなそうやってもう二人
二人一緒になって子供を作るんだと
で ＤＮＡのことまで言って
そういうふうなことで
このお互いに混ぜることで病気にならないで
元気で健康で長生きできるんだと
もしそうやって混ぜることなかったならば
もうすぐ亡くなってしまっちゃいますよと
子供はよく知っている恐竜とかいるんだからね
そういう恐竜やいろんな動物が亡くなったんだと
それでことが分かったかないか分かりませんだけど
もうすごいいろんなことを言うと
ああ そうですかと とにかく一応分かりましたからね
だからあんまりこの子供にはそんなこと分からないんだということじゃなくて
それは分かり 理解できるようにいろんな方法を使って教えるのはやっぱり先生の仕事なんですね
先生というのは親のことなんですけど
それから例えば教え方なんですけど
子供はもう例えばおにぎり食べていますね
よく子供たちが好きだから
おにぎり なんで好きでしょうかね
あれ 食べやすいからかもしれませんね
よくもうつかまれるし
まあ海苔はどんな子供でもね
大変好物ですからね 海苔もあるし
もう取りやすいし 食べやすいかもしれません
わかりません 私は小さい時
おにぎり食べなかったんだからわかりません
それで子供というのは
おにぎり食べながら床を触ったりする
私は日本の子供たちと親の感じをよくじっと見ているんですね
えらい清潔好きなんですけど
ものすごい不潔なんです
頭だけで清潔すぎて 実際には不潔なんです
そこで私だったら もう床やらいろんなみんなもう草履履いて歩いたりするところでね
子供はどうしてぺちゃぺちゃとそれ触ったりするんですね
それでおにぎりのもうご飯ちょっとでも落ちたら
すぐそれを拾って食べるんですね
大体の場合 親が何も言わないんですね
あんなめったもないこと大人もやってるんだから
それで私はそういうことはなんで気をつけるかというと
床っていうのはもう細菌だらけでしょうね
ホコリやら細菌やら汚いもの
それで子供の小さなもうもうなんてますだ平らだから
手は我々よりもきちんと
もうなんかもう猫の手みたいな感じでね
ふっくらしているでしょう
だからべったりとあのホコリやら細菌やら手に付くんですね
だからその場合は 子供にちょっとしたドラマで教えてあげればね
あー手の中でまあ細菌いっぱいだ
嫌だとかね お母さんのところに来るなよ
手が細菌だらけで汚いよとかね
あ 怖いと まあちょっと冗談でね
あ 私の食べ物だけは触らないでくださいとかね
これこれ汚い汚い あなたの手がもう汚く汚くなっちゃったんだからと
そんなことちょっと一回だけやっちゃうと
子供はすぐ勉強するんですね
このただ 見た目の清潔ではなくて
論理的な清潔はもっと必要だと
子供の服なんか汚れたって
これは大したことはないんです
食べる時はもう顔中ご飯あっちこっちやっても
これは別におったことはない
である 小さな赤ちゃんがね
なんか私は抱っこしてあげたら
もうすぐ私の手をつかまって
それもうさぶっちゃうんですね
自分の手はさぶらない
で これ私は冗談に言いながらね
まあ言いながら指を上げちゃいましたけど
すごくその赤ちゃんのところにいた時はものすごく気をつけたんです
自分の手が汚れないようにと
だから何か触ったらすぐ行ってもうこすこすと石鹸で手を洗っておく
なぜかというと 赤ちゃんを抱っこしちゃったら
すぐもう指に指を狙っちゃいますからね
ですから まあそういうふうな
例えばちゃんと手を洗いなさいよと命令するより
それは命令も必要ですけど
やっぱりその中にそれなりの理屈があるんだよと
そこはちょっとした面白いことで
もう冗談で言っちゃえばよく理解する
まあ大体どんな子供でもこのおかしいこと好きなんですね
で 子供が好きな漫画やらね
なんで子供はそれほどモンスターが好きですかね
どんな子供でも もうポケットの中でね
ポケモンのカードいっぱいあるでしょ
あんなもん大人から見れば何なのかと
これはと むちゃくちゃであれ
おかしいんだから もう変だから子供は好きなんです
だからもう子供っていうのは本当はしつけしやすいんです
だから だからなんか言う場合は
すごくドラマティックでオーバーに言う
自分はそれで漫才師になってちゃんと演じてみせる
それ親にとってもすごくリラックスできる気持ちいいものだと思いますね
だって自分の漫才 誰も聞いてくれませんだからね
だから そういうのを子供に日常生活のことはもう何か手を洗わないでご飯食べたこととかね
それはちょっとドラマにして
手を洗わなくてご飯食べてお腹が壊しちゃって
もうもう下痢を出したり
いろいろ苦労したりすることを自分でドラマでやっちゃえば
勝手に 子供はやっぱり聞いていないふりをするんだけど
ちゃんと聞いてるんです
あるちっちゃな女の子に
あの親がもうちゃんと自分のものはちゃんと自分で片付きなさいと教えてあって
で 女の子だから そういうのはちゃんとまあ言われたらやりますからね
それで その子の家で私はこのガムを食べたんですね
で 私は机でもう紙を拾い
拾い拾い拾いて まあガムを口に取ったら
まあまあいいです やっとことを喋れるぐらいですけどね
出てきて もうちゃんと自分でそのゴミをね
自分食べたものは自分でちゃんと片付けてくださいと私に言うんです
あんまり まあやっと言えたぐらいの日本語の能力なんですけど
まあ幼稚園には行ってなかったんですね
だから まあ言うことはちゃんと理解はしている
だから私はもう子供に負けたらね
子供に言われたら これは大人として立場がないんだから
でも これはもう君の家でしょ
だからゴミ箱は知りませんね
私がどこにあるかと 知ってますかと
うん 知ってますと じゃあこれちょうだいと言って
子供にもまた もう逆襲しちゃったんだけど
言われたんだから やっぱりそれでも私は何かちょっともう一つ教えてあげただけで
自分の家だから やっぱりお客さんにはちゃんと案内することも必要だよと
もし私が勝手に台所にいてゴミ箱に入れてたら
もう子供はその勉強はしない
大人にも言ってやったぞという気持ちになるでしょうね
だから私は人の子供でも
もうちょっと 30 分遊んであげても
これは大変な自分の勉強になるんだとは思ってるんです
ですから 親 たちがみんな子供からいっぱい学べるんだよと
覚えておけば まあちょっとちょっとやり方
例でそういうふうに言いましたけどね
例えば文字を教える時でも
もういろんなストーリーで
遊びで まああの恐竜やらね
まあそういうモンスターやらね
そういう言葉借りて 言うとすぐ早く覚えちゃうんですね
子供はひらがなの歯書こうと思って間書いたとする
それで歯の字にはもうなんとか
あの なんて言いますか
付き人必要だよと お連れがいるんだと
ママ一人でまあまあ大丈夫やと
でも歯はダメですよと
で たくさんなければね
そういうふうに これ私は今作った考え出した人で
やっぱりそれなりに自分の国の文字だったら
いろいろストーリー作ってあげないと
例えば自分の国の文字の場合は
なとたっていうのはほぼ似ているんです
子供には区別できないんで
ちょっと例で書いてみせます
上の字はなで 下の字はたなんです
どちらが違いますかね
これは外国の方々には外国っておかしいんだけど
自分の国の言葉を知らない方々にとってはえらい難しいと思いますよ
わかりますか？差はどこら辺違うかと
あの上はですね うん あのどっちかというと
あの 顔を上げてるんですね
うん そうですね  下はですね
固執してる  そうそうそう
その差なんですね それ
印刷文字になっちゃうと
もっとひどいんです もう手で書いたんだから
いくらかちょっと手の癖が入りますからね
こんなちょっとの差なんです
顔を上げてるか下げてるかってぐらいの
子供にとってはこれはえらい苦しいんですよ
だから子供に教えては
もう名はね お腹が空いて上見てるんだと
ただのお腹がいっぱい
だからもういらんと下向けてるんだと
ご飯にはスリランカ語でバットとバッタという言葉を使っても使っちゃうんです
だからご飯もそうでしょ
だからもうお腹がいっぱいで
お腹がいっぱいで 顔ももういらんと下見ているんだと
名はもうお腹が空いてるんだからもうちょうだいと顔を上げているんだというふうに言えば
子供にとってそれはちょっとしたストーリーなんですね
だから そのストーリーですぐ
覚えてしまう そうやって子供の世界っていうのは
いつでも楽しみがいっぱい世界なんですね
だから道徳を教える時でも
いつでも子供にその面白さっていうのは
楽しみっていうのは利用して指導しなくちゃいけないんです
それ 文字を教えるのは別に親の仕事ではないかもしれませんだけど
そんなことは学校でもできますけど
親の仕事は人間育てることなんですね
道徳を教えることなんです
それ どうやればいいんでしょうかね
例えば怒るなよと 怒るなよっていうことをどうやって教えればいいんですかね
それ その自分の家庭の環境から教えてあげてください
まあ今はちょっとあまり良い例じゃないんだけど
例えば子供が何とかのことで怒ったらね
で 君がね お母さんがカンカン怒るのは好きですか？と
あるいはいつでもお母さんがニコニコと笑っているのは好きですか？と
君のことを怒るのは好きですか？あるいは君のことを可愛がってあげるのは好きですか？と
そしたら答えは決まっててね
怒るのは嫌だと ですから
誰でも怒るのは嫌だよと
君もカンカン怒っちゃうとお母さんがものすごい嫌ですよと
それもちょっとオーバーには
もうすごい嫌ですねとかね
言ったらまあ怒ってはいけないということは
そこでなんとかわかるでしょうと思います
なんでもそうやってこの例を出して言うんです
大人よりも子供の頭っていうのはものすごい論理的なんです
我々から見れば なんだこの子は
というふうに気持ちはあるんだけど
すごい論理あるんです
例えば 子供がものすごい変な絵なんか描くでしょ
大人から見れば まあまあ
どうせ子供の絵だからということで
でも聞いてみてください
聞いてみたら そちらに理屈はあるんです
例えば人間の絵を描いて
頭の上で花があると風の描くかもしれません
それどう見ても変でしょうね
頭の上から花が咲くはずがないでしょうに
まあ子供だからそんな変なこと描くんだよということではなくて
子供に聞いてみていると
なんでこちらこの花があるんでしょうかと言ったら
自分が何を考えて描いたかということを教えてくれる
に 聞いて 聞いて 聞いてみれば
すごい論理的なんです
もしかすると その子が
いえ この人がさっきこの花畑で寝ていたんだよと
で だからそちら頭に花が咲いているんだということを言うかもしれません
その場合は その子供が花畑で寝ていた人がすごい気持ちよく起きたことを描いているんです
そんなに表現力ないんだから
もうそこはわからないだけのことで
だからその場合は感心できるんですね
ある子がこのちょっとした街を描いて
それなりに人も描いて
それからもうなんかもうブラウン色ですか
色で全部線でもう消しちゃったんですね
絵を完璧に もう見えない
描いたものは で 消してから偉そうに私に持ってくるんです
絵を描いたんだから はい
どうぞと 大人の目で見れば
自分描いて絵を全部むちゃくちゃむちゃくちゃブラウン色で茶色のクレヨンで消しちゃって
これちょっとどうかなと思うでしょうね
私は別にもう感動も何もなし
あの なんで君がこの絵を全部消しちゃったんですか？と言ったら
答えはこれは雨の音 だから結局
子供がこの雨の中の街を描いたんですね
だから子供の世界で雨が降る時
一番気になるのは音なんですね
すごい音ですからね だから音を描いたいんですよ
だから音を描いただけなんです
それで あ なるほど よくできてますと
全部消して音が強いということなんです
それを言ったのは この子供っていうのは
こんなもうふざけて遊んでいるんだけど
いい加減じゃないんです
ちゃんと論理的に物事を考えているんです
だから我々も子供にしつけするときは
すごく丁寧に 何でもこの
この変な理屈ではないんです
ただ論理的だけなんです
すごく緩やかな優しい論理で
で 自分の母親が自分が小さい時
鳥を捕まろうとしたところで
まあちょっとした箱の蓋をね
もう外を入れて そこで棒を一つ挿しておいて
ロープをつなげて もう家で隠れて待ってるんですね
餌を食べるために鳥来るまで
そこで棒を引っ張っちゃえば
もう箱の中に鳥が捕まれるんですね
それ狙ってもう二人で待っていると
この母に見つかったんですね
母に見つかったら 母言うのは
まあ君を誰かがそうやってね
罠をかけて捕まって持っていったとする
どこかに知らないところに持っていって
何か檻に入れて出られないように鍵かけておくと
どうですかね その時はと
だから母親言うことだから
インパクト強く心に響くんですね
そうするといきなり頭の中でイメージが出来上がっちゃったんですね
誰か自分を知らない人が自分を捕まえて
何か檻に入れて鍵をかけて入れておくと
私は考え そこでお母さんに会えなくなっちゃう
遊ぶこともできなくなっちゃう
お母さんのご飯も食べられなくなっちゃうと
そこを頭にイメージが出てきたんですね
あ これ悲しいんだと やっぱりやってはアカンと
それでもう動物いじることをやめてしまったんです
そういう風に小さい時
いろんな道徳を教えてくれたんだけど
正直にすることと 嘘を言ってはいけないことと
もう約束したことはちゃんとやること
何でも全部この自分の人生の中からイメージを湧くようにして
イメージが湧くようにして教えたんです
それでまあ一生どんな人間で生きるべきかということは
母親がもうちゃんと叩き込んじゃうんですね
独立するべきであることも
ちょっとしたことであっても
母が結構病気になるということするんですね
もうこれでもう大変だと
それで子供たちってわがまま言うんだからね
病気になったりしたっても
ご飯どう食べるんでしょうかとかね
そういうわがままを言われるまでなんとなくいるんですね
言ったらすぐ言うのは
私たちはもうもう年だからすぐ死んじゃいますよと
あんた方はずっと母に甘えるつもりですか？と
自分のことを自分でできなかったら
もう生きていられませんよと
人はいつ死ぬかわかりませんと
兄弟喧嘩するときでも
あんた方はずっと一緒にもう仲良くしないすることになってるんだと
両親っていうのは 母親も父親も先に死んじゃいますよと
そういう風なことを言っちゃうで
やっぱり兄弟喧嘩してはいけないとかね
いくら嫌でも我慢してでもいなくちゃあかんと
いつでも母が来て守ってくれるわけじゃないんだと
そこで愛情についても
自分の母が教えたのは
それは自分で努力して買うものであって
ただで貰うものじゃないんだと
だから子供は一人しかないと
もうやりたい放題のことをやってあげるでしょうね
それはすごい 子供にとってはものすごい悪いことなんですね
だから私 これは兄弟横綱
家族横綱だったらね 簡単ですけどね
だから良いことをすれば
もうそれなりに言うことをちゃんと聞いて
きちんと正しい生き方をするならば
母親がよく褒めて ちょっとかわいがってくれる
ほんのちょっとだけ そういうこと何もなくても
ただ一日中遊んだだけだったら
だいたいほとんど無視されちゃうんですね
まああなたもいるんですかという態度なんですね
自分の母親が そこで一日何かもう何かいいことをしたら
もう母親のおとしだいやら
家の何かとか なんとかね
掃除でもしてあげたら
まあそこでちょっと褒めてくれる
それも少々 大胆ではないんですね
それで自分が何を学んだかというと
人に助けて欲しければ
人に面倒見て欲しければ
自分がそれ努力して買わなくちゃいけないんだと
その技はもうずっと 自分にも役に立ちましたからね
だってもう十三になったところで
もうお寺に入ったし 全く知らない世界で
そこで子供としてはすごく寂しくなる可能性ありましたし
いじめられる可能性もありましたし
どこでもそういうことには遭ったことはないんです
自分で計算して まあこの人には怒られてもどうでもいいやということの人の場合はあまり気にしない
でも この人が親切にしてくれなかったら
自分が大変やと ということはちゃんと理解して
まあその人々に可愛がってもらうように
いろいろないろいろなことをするんです
だから 一旦大学に入った時からもう自分で
この先生はすごく頭が鋭そうやと
いろんなことを知ってるやと
だったら その先生に何とかして接近する
接近して 自分をアピールして
なんとか 印象を埋めておくんですね
印象を埋めて とにかく愛情を買ってもらうんですね
それでもうそれで大丈夫です
なんでも心配してくれるし
何か間違ってもすごく優しくね
教えてくれるし だから
この専門的なこと以外
人間としていろんなことを
そういう先生方はね もう何から何まで教えてくれる
だから大人の世界で生きていた時でも
すごく気持ちが分かったんですね
ですから 母親を教えることっていうのは一生役に立つ大変大事なこと
そこは覚えてほしいんですね
まとめて結論で言うならば
両親の仕事っていうのは人間育てること
どこにいても立派な人間になること
会社の社長になろうか
もうただのサラリーマンでなろうか
やっぱり自分が立派な人間で生きていられる
人に嘘をつかない 人を騙すということはしない
しない ちょっとしたことでカンカンと怒らない
忍耐はある 何かやりたければ
何か獲得したければ いちいち文句言わないで
どんな苦しみも自分で決めたものだから
それは乗り越える そういう風なこの人格ですね
だから短い言葉で覚えてください
両親の仕事は子供の人格を形成することですね
それは学校の仕事でもありますけどね
宿題のお手伝いすることは別にどうでもいいんで
そんなことは できるんだったらやってもよろしいし
まあ忙しいんだったらまあ放っておいてください
それは勝手にしなさい
あんたの宿題でしょうと
やってもやらなくても
お母さんが学校に行かないんだから大丈夫やと威張っちゃえばいいんです
お母さんは大丈夫や 宿題やってもやらなくても怒れませんと
ただ 怒られる人がいるんだったら
自分で宿題すればいいでしょうというふうな態度でも
別にどうったことはないんです
でも 人格は形成することはやっぱり親の仕事なんですね
えーと あの それからいろいろ経典からあの
話を続けていきたいんですが
えーと どうですかね 疲れたでしょうかね
じゃあ次のポイントに入る前に
あの前の今まで喋ったことの結論として覚えてほしいことを言いますけど
この親にはこの愛情っていうのは危険です
愛情というのは苦しみしか作ってくれないんです
子供に対する愛情ではなくて
慈しみなんです 必要なのは
仏教はやっぱり愛とかね
そういう執着とかね そういうのはすごく危険だと
どこだと 苦しみしか何一つも作ってくれないんだと
頭がおかしくなるんだと
バカになるんだと 愛情で
欲情で頭いっぱいになったら
もう完璧にアホになるんです
何もわからなくなっちゃうんです
だからバカになることだけはものすごい良くないんですね
バカな人は 狂った人は何するかわからないでしょ
世の中の両親たちっていうのは
子供に対してものすごい強烈な愛情を持ってるんですね
だから何一つもわからない
頭狂ってるんです それですごい苦しみが生まれてくる
我慢できなくなる 子供のためなら人殺しでもする
そこは苦しみの道なんですね
その代わりにお釈迦様がおっしゃったのは
慈しみを育てなさいと
それは独立した人間であって
自分に責任ある 立派な人と育ててあげることは
そこで地球人の地球の一人として育てるんだと
慈しみっていうのは全然この苦しみは作ってくれないんです
そこは大事なポイントで
この愛情を捨てて 子供に対してやっぱりすごくこの慈しみを育てる
慈しみっていうのは これ私のものではありませんということなんです
でも すごい大事な命 私の命ではありません
私のものではありません
ですから 大事な命ですから
大事に幸せで幸福でいてほしいと
間違いを起こしてほしくないと
例えば 自分の子供が学校で他の子供をいじめたとする
それ見つかったら 子供
親がもうむちゃくちゃでしょうに
うちの子はそんなことはしませんと
何と言うんでしょうかとか
そういう態度をするんですね
そう そういう態度をとっちゃうと
学校もいじめの問題は処理できなくなっちゃうんです
どうせいじめるんだったら子供にも問題あるんだけど
それも親の愛情がないっていうことですけど
愛情というか優しさがないんだからなんですが
それでいきなり子供がトラブルを起こしたところで
偉そうに愛情あるんだということは子供に見せようとする
いて 子供さえも自分がやったことは良くないとわかっているのに
親が弁解するんですね
そういう変なことをするんだから
もう学校にしたっても
教える先生たちと もう両親の間ではそれほど仲のいい関係じゃないんですね
だから慈しみさえあれば
自分の子供が悪いことをしたら
それは全くもう何のことなく
あ なるほど うちの子が悪いんだと
それは認めて 認めて認めてあげないと
ですから その時にやっぱり世の中で悪いことは悪い
良いことは良い これはたとえあなた
私の娘であろうか 息子であろうか
悪いことをしたら 両親にはどうすることもできないんだと
あんた犯罪を起こしたら
あんた犯罪者であると
私は守ってくれると思ったら
それは勘違いだと 私には何もできませんと
あんたは世の中の人間ですからね
世の中の考え方か 論理じゃなくて倫理や道徳をね
それは理解して行動しなくちゃいけないんだと
そういうふうに言えるんですね
慈しみさえあれば ですから
正しい 正しく子供を育てる秘訣は
もう愛情を捨てて慈しみを育てるということなんですね
そこでちょっと五分ぐらいお休みをいただいて
経典の話に入ります ものすごいたくさんありますけどね
言いたいことは  あの 仏教の世界で
これからちゃんと仏教の話だけに絞りますが
仏教の世界でもやっぱりよく子供を預かって育てて育ててきたということは
我々歴史的にもあることで
で お釈迦様の時代でもね
まあそういう親のない子供たちとかね
見つかったらまあお寺というかね
まあ連れていくんですね
まあ連れて行って まあ育てるんだけど
決して再婚の人を通して育てることはしなかったんですね
お寺に連れてきて 出家させて
もう比丘として修行僧として育ててあげたりはしていたんですね
ですから この子供のことについては結構
情報はあるんです で 不思議なことをこの
お寺に入って 例えば子供を大人が育てるようになっても
まあ人間だからこの情が出てくるということがあるんですね
子供の面倒を見ちゃうと
どうせもうなんとなく情というのは出てくるんですね
それはものすごい厳密に禁止しているんです
情なんかは欲ですから
それはダメだよ お互いに苦しいだけ
子供にしたって 知らない人々に一生懸命育ててくれると申し訳なくて
申し訳なくて 子供にとってもストレス多いんです
まあ親はもう別にみんなあまり気にしませんだけど
他人がね 子供の面倒を一生懸命我が子のように育てると
すごくストレスたまっちゃうんですね
これ アメリカでも行くときあります
アメリカではもう平気で子供を養子にするでしょ
それはみんな立派な方々で
全くもう全くも自分の子供のように育てる
大きい文化だから 何のことなく広い文化だからね
それはできます 日本では無理かもしれませんだけど
それで子供は知らないんですね
自分が小さい時 赤ちゃんの時
どこから施設からもらった人やということを
でも法律的にはになってくると
子供が聞いたら言わなくちゃいけない
になってくるともう大人でしょ
だからもう調べると どうせ自分の両親にはもう子供は生まれないということをわかる
簡単に どうせ一緒に生活していたんだから
わかったけど それで私はどうやってきたということ？問題が出ている
聞いたらもう大体先に気がつくんだけど
両親は言わない になったところでもう言わなくちゃいかない
それで言っちゃうでしょうし
言ったら自分の親を探すんですね
元の親を だから育てた親は全く自分の子供だと思っているんだけど
やっぱりその育ての親が全く
もう自分を産んだ親が誰ですかと
父親は誰ですか？探しちゃうんですね
探してどうということはないんだけど
どうせ最初から捨てられちゃったんだから
やっぱりそこら辺理解しないんですね
なぜかというと この一生懸命育てられたんだということがわかったら
ものすごく申し訳なくなっちゃうんですね
自分がわがまま言ったり
喧嘩したり やりたい放題なことをやったり
それは全部こらえて我慢して育てたんだから
悲しい時も もう悲しい
一緒に悲しんであげたりとか
いろいろなことをやってくれたんだから
これえらい申し訳ないんですね
それで子供はショックを受けちゃって
自分の本当の親って何なのかと
本当の親だったら こんなに苦しい思いをしないで済んだんではないかと思っちゃうんですね
だから そういうことっていうのは
育てられた親に 子供にしたっても
育てた親にしたっても悲しいんですね
すごい悲しいことになっちゃうんですね
なんでそうなるかというと
ここにそこに情があるんだからなんです
だから仏教でそれはやってはいけませんと
慈しみでやってくださいと
そうするともうすごい申し訳ない
申し訳ないという もうなんとかということにはならないんですね
お互いにものすごくこの慈しみでありがたいとことで
この人間関係は切れないんですね
感謝の気持ちは全く切れないんですね
だから自分が産んだ子供であるとも
やっぱり人間の一人として育てるんだということを育てると
やっぱりよく育ててくれたんだという感謝が残る
仏教の世界で子供を預かる場合は
必ずしももう 一人前の人にしてあげるんだということぐらいだけ考えてやっているんだから
まあ問題は起きません
ほとんどの場合は そこである経典がありまして
これ大変有名な経典で
仏教は子育て育児論ではなくて
人間論なんですね 人間どのように育てればいいかということで
仏教の育児論というのは
大人になるまで 年取るまで
死ぬまでの話なんです
14歳  18歳に 18歳
二十歳になるまでの話じゃないんです
ですから 仏教の育児方法っていうのは
生まれてから死ぬまでのシステムを教える方法なんです
それは全部まとめて教えた経典があります
そちらのポイントだけ一つ一つ申し上げます
全部 1番目 お釈迦様が大事に気をつけて欲しかったのは
この 悪い人といわる頭の悪い人な性格と頭なんですね
性格と頭の悪い人と付き合うなよと
なんででしょうかというと
この子供 赤ちゃんの時からもう周りを見て子供は習っちゃうんですね
親が変なことをしちゃうと
子供全くやっぱり同じことをやってしまっちゃうしね
親の言葉に訛りがあると
必ずも子供にも訛りが入っちゃうでしょうに
親が乱暴な言葉を使っちゃうと
必ず子供もそういうことを使うでしょ
だから子供っていうのは見て学ぶ
見て学ぶなんですね いわゆるもう真似の専門家なんですね
何でも真似てみる だったら良い人々の環境を作ってあげないと
子供は何真似すればいいんですかね
そこは一番大事なことで
もし自分がたとえ乱暴な人間であろうとも
自分に子供が生まれてきたら
その瞬間から行儀よく
もう正しく生きる人間にならなくちゃいけない
言葉正しく使う もうちゃんと
もうご飯食べる時でも
寝る時でも 何でもきちんとやる人間になればいいんですね
それは自分のためにもなるし
子供のためにもなる 子供がもう真似っ子の専門家で
ですから 悪いことは真似る
真似る 真似ることできないように
まず環境を作るということ
それは 1番目 ですから
2番目に言っているのは
その同じ言葉の反対 パンディターなんちゃせよなというパーリ語なんですけど
智慧のある人々と仲良くさせてあげてくださいと
それは子供でも大人でもみんなに同じなんです
子供にでもいろいろ能力ある人々を友達にしてあげる
だから必ずもこの同じ年の仲間っていうのはいいわけでもないんですね
いくらか年上のグループに入った方が子供にとってはいいと思いますけどね
昔 社会だったらやっぱり大きな家族で
村で育つ られちゃったんだから
遊び相手っていうのはいつでも同じ年っていうわけじゃないんですね
時々歳 の男の子が まあ歳 の男の子の遊び相手になってあげるとかね
ありますからね それ二人ともにもいいことなんですね
歳 の男の子はものすごいもういかすら好きで乱暴なこと好きな年ですけど
自分と一緒にいるのはちっちゃな子供だったらすぐ親になっちゃうんですね
面倒を見る あ それはダメだ
これは危険やとかね だから大人
この大人のこの性格も直せるし
子供にしたってもよくいろんなことを教えてくれる友達だから
もうすごくいいことなんですね
例えば同じ年の仲間だったら
もう勉強すること何一つもない
それも必要なんですけど
パンディターなんてせよなっていう
やっぱり頭のいい人々の仲間を作ってあげてくださいと
だからとにかくもう頭の良いことをですね
いわゆる道徳判断をちゃんとできる
判断能力ある人間になることはすごく大事なことなんです
頭のいいっていうことは
もう皆様思っているような
学校に行って勉強できるという
そんなくだらんでことではないんです
どんなバカな人にも勉強ぐらいはできますからね
それは頭のいいっていうことじゃないんで
やっぱり判断能力ある
特に道徳の世界で良いこと悪いこと
きちんと論理的に判断能力があるっていうことはすごい頭のいいことなんですね
それから番目に言ったのは
この敬うこと 敬うことに値するべき人々を敬うことを習うことですね
だからいきなりみんな平等だ平等だとかね
それはちょっと子育てには危ないんですね
例えばもう日本でよく見られることで
いつでもお母さんが子供に謝るんですね
あ ごめんごめんとかね
そんなことをずっとやっちゃうと
えらい性格が悪くなるんですね
私 実際にそういう一つのケースは知ってます
親に向かって子供が謝れと怒鳴りつける
私が見たら 別に親が謝るぐらいのこと何もやってないし
子供が悪いことしているのに理解していないんですね
自分が悪いと 好き勝手にわがままで親が悪いんだと
自分のわがままを聞いてくれなかったんだと
それでなんでそういうことになったかというと
この変な西洋的な思考で
みんな平等やと思って
平等じゃないんです 子育ての場合は
の場合は ですから 私たち死ぬまで
やっぱり尊敬するべき人々が我々の社会にいっぱいいるんですね
頭下げなくちゃいけない
話を聞いていただかなくちゃいかない
指導してもらわなくちゃいけない
そういう人間っていうのはいつでもいるんですね
もし私が世界一頭の良い人で
世界一できた人間であるならば
誰もいませんだけどね
それはありえないことでしょうに
それは絶対ありえないんです
人間というのは完璧になれないし
例えば  何て言いますか
ノーベル賞をもらうかもしれませんだけど
日本の一人の方がノーベル賞をもらったんだからって
この方がすべてのことを知っているわけじゃないでしょ
ある一つのことは もうノーベル賞をもらうところまでできているんであって
まだ知らないことはいっぱいありますね
世の中で それはその都度その都度
その人が教えてもらわなくちゃいかない
ですから たとえノーベル賞をもらうぐらいの能力のある知識人であろうとも
敬うべき人々を敬う性格ないと
それは小さいところ教えてあげないと
えらい気持ち悪い 頑固な役に立たない人間になるんですね
ですから あの ある これスリランカの子供なんですけど
この日本に来て会って話したんだところなんですけど
この うん 仏教では親に礼しなくちゃいけないんですね
仏法僧に礼をすることと全く同じ形で
皆様はこの仏像の前でお寺に
どんなお寺に行ってもちゃんと手を合わせてあの礼拝するでしょ？で
我々の仏教になると このお釈迦様の前で
仏法僧の前でお寺に行ってもう礼拝することだけじゃなくて
自分の両親にも同じくやらなくちゃいけないんです
僕はもう全く平気でやってますけどね
だからこのスリランカの家族でしたから
スリランカの文化によって日本の文化は違いますけど
文化で子供に両親にもちゃんと礼をしなさいということを教えなくちゃいけなくなっちゃったんですね
おじいちゃんおばあちゃんなんか
誰か誰かいるんだったら
それは何のことなく教えられる
まねっこだから なぜかというと
自分のお父さんがおじいさまにものすごく礼をする
自分のお母さんも頭を下げて礼をする
それ見ると子供まねっこだから
やっぱりおじいさんおばあさんに礼をするでしょ
その瞬間でおじいさんおばあさんが
じゃあお父さんにもお母さんにもちゃんとやってちょうだいと言うんですね
それで子供たちと これ楽しい仕事で
何のことなく身についてしまっちゃうんですね
これでもう夫婦だけで子供連れて日本に来てしまったところで
これもう教えてあげなくちゃいけない年になったら
これを教えなくちゃいけない
できない なぜならば ちゃんと自分に礼をしなさいと言えませんだから
いくらなんでも 一応言ったところで
子供がそれを訳聞いたんですね
なんで人間なのにみんな礼をしなくちゃいけないんですかと聞いちゃったら
もうその夫婦もいい加減な夫婦で
仏教ぐらいちょっと勉強しておけばね
答えられるのに答えられなくて
子供はこういう風に言うんだけど
困ったもんやと 何も言えないんだと
でもしきたりやらね 習慣というのもこともやっぱり勉強した方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
そういう問題をとにかく起きたんですね
ですから この小さい時から
我々は子供っていうのはまねっこだから
やっぱり目上の人々を敬うように
尊敬するように この価値観を入れてあげる
それで子供はなんで？と聞いたら
はっきり教えればいいんです
ちゃんと先生に礼をしなさい
なんでと だってお前何も知らんでしょうに
これから先生が全部教えてあげるでしょうに
だから礼をしなきゃいけませんと
礼をしたら あんたは立派な人間だと
よくできた子やと 先生はあなたのことをすごくかわいがってくれるんだと
そうすると親切に教えてくれるんだと
なんかヘマでもやっても
先生はまあまあいいやと言って
それは何とかしてあげるんだと
何でおじいちゃんに礼をしなくちゃ
だっておじいちゃんというのは
もう私たちを育ててくれたのおじいさんでしょうに
ご飯食べさせたり 面倒見てくれたりしたのおじいさんだから
君たちもいないでしょうと
だからもうちゃんと礼をしなさいと
そうやって尊敬に値するべき人々に尊敬できるような性格を立てる
なぜ私 お釈迦様が尊敬に値するという形容詞を使ったかというと
ただ目上の人をお読みなさいという風な
このフラットで言わないんですね
たとえ年上であろうとも
だらしない人間 犯罪者とかね
そんな礼をする必要はないんです
やっぱりその場合は やっぱりこの人の生き方が良くないんだと
人間にとっては迷惑だと
この人の生き方が それは子供も理解するでしょう
で だから自分も礼をしなくたってもいいんだと
それさえもよく良い教育なんですね
やっぱり人間としては道徳正しい立派な人間にいなくちゃいけないということ
ですから お釈迦様はわざとこの尊敬に値する人々に尊敬するようにと
その習慣つけてあげてくださいと
次に出てくるのは この環境
良い環境を選んでくださいと
それは大人にも子供にも同じなんですね
立派な人間として育てやすい
生活しやすい 環境を選ばなくちゃいけない
例えば この黄金三角地帯ありますね
ミャンマーやらタイやら
このラオスやら そこら辺の全部境界線ばっかりあるところで
このゴールデンというところがあるんですね
だから どんな国から見てもものすごい遠い田舎なんですね
だから政治的な力も全然入らない
全く田舎であって 隣の国の境界線でありますからね
まあ放っておくんですね
そこら辺は それで その人々にとってはもう政治家もいないし
警察も来ないし もうもう好き勝手に生きていられる
でも誰も面倒見てくれない
それでもうこの人々が麻薬
売買しましょう 売買じゃない
何て言いますか えっ 作るんですね
作って作って それは製造してもう売ったりする
だからどんな人でもやっぱり麻薬のその畑作ってるんですね
誰も悪いと思ってないんですね
なぜかというと それでちゃんと 1 日の給料をいただくんだから
それで食べているんだから
それでアメリカが怒っても
アメリカが自分の国に麻薬が入らないように法律を作らないで
三角地帯 その国々に文句を言うんですね
あんた方は作るなよと
そんないい加減なことを言ったっても
その人々にとっては他の生きる方法はないんですね
米は作れないし 教育もないし
学校もないし それでもし日本の誰かが土地が安いんだからといって
そこら辺の土地を買ってしまえばどうなるかというと
そちらは教育システムもない
警察もいない もう麻薬売人に支配されていて
政治はそちらがやっていて
日本の家族をそちらに行ったら
その人言う通りにやらなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
あんたが威張るんじゃなくて
この工場ぐらい手伝ってくださいと
もっと品質の日本人だからね
もっと品質の高い 純度が高い麻薬を作るように頑張りなさい
そうでなきゃ殺してやるぞと言っちゃったらどうしますかね
やらなくちゃいけないことになりますね
ですから 環境を選ぶということはとても大事なことなんです
たとえ自分が生まれた田舎であろうとも
子育てに 自分の人生にうまく適応してない場合は
その場所を離れるんだと
だからお釈迦様は私の土地
代々通して伝わってくる土地とか
そういうくだらない価値観を入れてないんです
土地は捨てていくものであって
人間で死ぬ 生まれた時から死ぬまで立派に生きているかということはもっと大事だよと
仏教から見れば 国捨てたってもどうったことないんです
それはすごい寂しいんですけど
それでも自分にとっては
自分の家族にとっては良いことがなければ
もう国でも捨てちゃったっても
それはどうったことない
なぜならば 人間生きることはもっと大事なんです
人間が幸せに生きることは
変な名前を付けている国の名前よりも大事なんです
いい加減にあちこち境界線を作ったりしてね
お互いに喧嘩したり 殺し合いやったりする
バカなことでしょう ただの土地のために殺し合いやっていて
そういうのはバカバカらしいし
だからもうどこでも人間っていうのは
死ぬまで幸せで豊かで道徳の人間で生きてほしいんだから
場所を選べと それ 4番目の決まりなんです
子供にとっても同じこと
子供にすごい立派に教育してあげたければ
それなりの環境 教育のある場所を選ばなくちゃいけない
子供にいろんな技術を身につけてほしいければ
そういう場所を選ばなくちゃいけない
子供は立派なバラバラ
バレリーナにしたければ
ソ連にでも行かなくちゃいけないんだから
しょうがないんです そこで次にあるのは
この 過去で良いことがしたことがあるという項目なんです
これ すごい意味取りにくい言葉なんですね
いわゆる過去で徳を積んだことがあること
これどういうことですかね
この徳を積んだということは
自分が悪いことをしていないということなんです
恥じることは何一つもやっていないんだと
隠すことは何もないんだ
自分の人生で だから小さい時からもう恥じること
バレたらまずいこと 知られたらもう大変になることっていうのは一つもやらないように気をつける
そうすると どこにいたっても大丈夫なんです
例えば 私は自分の国で犯罪を起こしたとします
犯罪を起こしちゃったりして
もう日本に逃げている
日本で犯罪を起こしていないんだから
堂々と胸を張って喋ったりする
でも もしそれはバレちゃったら
日本の法律では何の問題もないんだけど
やっぱりみんなの前で堂々と喋ることもできないし
この国で幸せで生きることもできなくなるでしょうに
大体よくこの国際的な犯罪を起こる人々っていうのは
すぐ国を逃げちゃうんですね
逃げてどこかで隠れて偉そうにそこでも生活するんだけど
結局そちらでもやるのは犯罪ですけどね
だから結局自由に生きていられないんですね
国から逃げても 日本で殺人を犯して
もうアメリカやらフランスどこかで逃げているんだと言ったっても
生活は自由じゃないんですね
幸せじゃないんですね
だから赤十字の人々やらね
日本の政府はいまだにもう追っているんだから
返せ返せと たとえもう中東の方やらね
もう北朝鮮の方でいても
あれで立派な生活をしているんだということを言えますかね
やっぱり過去でいいことをしたことがないんだから
人生不幸になる ですから
人間っていうのはすっごく気をつけて
バレたらまずいこと 知られたらまずいこと
全くしないように気をつけて生活するということは
これは大事だよと これは子供の人生から大人まで大事な生き方なんですね
次のポイントはアッタサンマーパニディという言葉で
自分の自己管理ですね
正しく自己管理をできる人間になる
いわゆる感情に 今の子供たちみたいにちょっとしたことでもカッとなるとかね
あれ病気なんですけどね
食べ物のせいだと思いますけどね
いきなりものすごくカッとなって自分を見失うんですね
何するかわからなくなっちゃう
時々みんなストレス溜まって
人を誰でもいいんだから人を殺したくなったぞとかね
そりいい加減でしょ 自分にストレス溜まったんだからといって
誰でも人を殺してしまっちゃうんですね
公園なんかに人が寝ていたら行ってぶん殴って殺しちゃう
オヤジ狩りとか言葉まで作ったりして
こう仕事をして 苦労して苦労で疲れて疲れて
やっと家に帰る この男性の人々は狙って殴ったり蹴ったりする
やりたい放題 向こうももう喧嘩できないし
もう疲れてるんだから
相手が若者だから力もあるでしょうに
またグループで来るんだからね
みんな間抜けないんだから
一人では喧嘩しない グループを組んで喧嘩するでしょ
喧嘩だったら堂々と一対一でやればね
まあ立派ですけど それもできない
間抜けない グループを組んで人を殺したりする
ですから やっぱりこのすぐカッとなったりするし
感情はコントロールできない
性格は良くない ですから
自己管理できるように
小さい時からも我々は子供に教えてあげる
大人になって我々今からでも自己管理できる人間になるということは必要なんですね
次にお釈迦様がおっしゃるポイントは
バーフサッチャンチャシッパンチャということ
それはよく勉強しなさいよと
いろんな技術を学んでくださいと
人間というのは勉強と技術でなければ生きていられないんです
犬猫と違いますからね
犬猫にしたっても それなりの技術は身についてますけど
だから勉強嫌だ 嫌いだ
じゃあ嫌だったらやめましょうとかね
そういうのはそんな甘い甘えすぎですね
だからもう人間 言葉を使ってる
言葉でも勉強しなくちゃいけないですね
文字使ってるで それ勉強しなくちゃあかんでしょうに
わがままはできません
だからもう人間であるならば
我々はずっといろんなことを勉強しなくちゃいけない
小さい時から当たり前で
大人になっても新しいことを新しいことを勉強していかなくちゃいけないんです
それはものすごい楽しいことで
年取ったんだからやめたと言ったら暗いでしょうに
年取ってもいいんですよ
新しいことにチャレンジする
英語の勉強でもやってみる
コンピューターでもいじってみるとかね
今の年になって あんた何てやって何やってるかということよりも
やっぱり時間無駄に使わないで
何か新しいことを勉強するという
それから新しいいろんな技術をね
何か何か何かいつでも知っておく
いつでも知っておく だからもう会社にしたっても
みんなこの時代遅れになっちゃうんですね
どんどんと時間経つと技術は改良するわ
もう会社のシステムが変わるわ
それで四十五歳ぐらいの歳の人々はもうもう追いつけなくなくなって
どんどんどんどん後ろに下がっちゃうでしょうに
そうすると若者に追い越されちゃうし
自分の仕事を危うく状態になってしまっちゃうし
だから仏教は時代遅れになることはあまり認めない
いつでも時代の先端にいなくちゃいけないんですね
何が変わっても それはすごい簡単です
すごく面白く世の中を見ていると
まあどうったことない
明日理解できないほど世界が発展するかというと
それは絶対ありえないでしょうに
今日の延長線の明日でしょうに
だから明日のことは理解できます
そういうことだから 死ぬまで世界はどう変わっても
もう対応できます ですから
そのポイント 勉強しなさいということ
勉強と同時に次に必要なヴィナヨオチャスセッキと道徳
自己管理できるって前言ったんだけど
ちょっと似ているような感じもしますけど
道徳を勉強しなさいと
いわゆる嘘をついてはいけないとかね
人のものを取ってはいけないとか
まあ約束を守らなきゃダメですよとかね
そういういろいろ道徳あるでしょうに
ちゃんと勉強だけではダメでしょうし
ちゃんと道徳を持っていること
それは子供にしたっても
大人にしたっても同じことなんです
次のポイントはスバーシタートヤーワーチャということで
美しい言葉を語れと いわゆる語る者が洗練したものを語ってくださいと
感情でぺちゃぺちゃぺちゃぺちゃしゃべるのは
仏教ではあまり認めない
しゃべるものは 聞く人にも理解できるようにちゃんと管理して
考えた上でしっかりした言葉でしっかりした発音で喋ってほしい
それは大変なことで この人間の文化っていうのは
もう言葉の文化であって
もうえらいことでしょうに
ちょっと舌が滑っちゃったらもう大変なことになるでしょ
日本はもうなんか誰かなんか言っちゃってね
なんか神の国やなんとか言っちゃって大変なことになったでしょうに
だからまあそんないい加減に言葉をしゃべるということを気をつけた方がいいんですね
まあ本人が別にどうったかなんも思わないで
まあ日本は神の国だからとか
なんとか言ったかもしれませんだけど
でもそれはちゃんと客観的に見てみると
もう大変な問題を受けてしまう
ですから 人間というのは
言葉っていうのはすべての災いの元
だから一切の苦しみの元
戦争の元 ですから 言葉だけは気をつけてほしい
言葉だけではなくて 言葉にはとことん気をつける
時々この子供は親の言うことをなぜ聞かないかというと
親がしゃべるわ しゃべるわ
しゃべるわ しゃべるわ
きりがなくしゃべる だから子供から見ればどうせうるさいんだから
同じことを回ぐらい言うんだからと
だから一回聞いて 回聞いてもう聞かなくてもいいやということになるでしょう
だから 聞く耳は持てなくなっちゃうんですね
大事なことしか言わない場合は
何か喋ったら気をつけて聞く
だから子育ての場合も結構失敗あるのは
このよくしゃべる みんなこの遊びで喋ってるんだったらいいんだけど
これもうこのしつけなんですね
だから耳に 耳に入らなくなっちゃう
ですから 言葉の管理大変大事です
まあそういうことはもう子供の時から習うところで
それで人がまあどんどん歳ぐらいになってくる
二十歳ぐらいになってくるでしょ
そんな生き方やっていると
環境も選んで 教育も受けて
技術も身について 言葉の管理もできて
道徳も知っていて 自己管理もできて
良い仲間もいて 敬う目上の人々を敬う人間になったところで
もう二十歳ぐらいの立派な大人になってくるんですね
それで次の仕事があるんです
マーターピトゥパッターナ
自分の両親の面倒を見なさいと
自分が一人前になってくると
両親がもうどんどん中年になってくるんですね
そこから両親から今まで散々お世話になってもらったんだから
これからもうお返しの時間ですね
ですから 必ずも両親をの面倒を見ること
だから その年によって変わります
両親がすごく病気になって倒れちゃったら
まあそれはそれなりに看病する
まあただまあ中年ぐらいになってきたら
それなりに両親のことを面倒見ればいいんです
とにかくこの状況を判断しながら
両親のことは一生忘れないで
感謝の気持ちでやってあげることは何一つも欠けることなくやってあげると
それは人間として大事な仕事なんです
私は忙しいんだからといってとんでもない話なんです
忙しいことはそんなにえらいことでもなんでもないんです
あなたは作ったのはこの二人だから
あなたの人生を幸せになるためには
両親の面倒を見なくちゃいけないんです
それで生きる喜びを感じるんです
後で悔しくなるだけでね
父親が倒れちゃったんだけど
看病にはお見舞いには一度も行けなかったんだとかね
ある人が最近言ったんですよ
私に 父親が死んじゃったんだけど
まああの お葬式にも行かなかったんだと
半年かヶ月とか後で電話したら
見せてみたら 父親は亡くなって全部終わったんだよと
もう家から一旦くれたんだと
本人がえらいことをやっているような感じで言うんで
私はものすごく怒鳴ったんですね
そこでまた仏教の人だから
だから会って話すことになりましたからね
あんた偉そうに仏教ぶってるんだけど
人間にもなってないんだと
基本的な人間にもなってないんだと
何ですか それは威張ることやことかと
たとえ何があっても 父親がね
そうやって倒れちゃったらね
いてそばにいてあげるということは
やってあげる人にもすごい生きる喜びを感じられるし
父親にしたっても ものすごい良い気持ちで
死にかけている人々にとっては
自分の子供たちが周りにいることほどありがたいことはないんですよ
ですから 親の面倒を見ること
それからブッダダーラササンガホもう結婚適齢になってくるんだからね
それまあ相手と子供たちの面倒を見なさいということでね
まあそれは大体当たり前のことで
それでちょっと日本で感じたことがありますけど
なんか時々なんか奥さんのことをあまり大事にしない人々を私は知ってるんですね
まあなんかもうもう自分の父親のおばさん
お母さんの面倒を見る
それはあなたの仕事ではないかと
奴隷買ったと思ってるんですかね
自分が全く別な家から人をもらったんだから
その人のことをものすごく大事にしなくちゃいけないんですね
それは自分の両親の面倒を見たならば
それはすごくありがたいことやと
あんたは本当に申し訳ない
よくやってくれたんだと
私のお父さんの面倒をよく見てくれたんだと
それぐらい気持ちがないと幸せでは生きていられませんね
そういうことで 自分の奥さんやら子供たちの面倒を見るという仕事が次に出てくる
で それからアナワッジャーニカンマーニという言葉がありまして
この罪を犯さないこと
仕事とかいろんなことをやるでしょうに
ですから その時でもやっぱりもう間違った仕事とかしないで
ちゃんとした生き方をすることになっています
それからアーレティヴィラティパーパという
それも同じ意味で罪を犯さない
やっぱりもう酒に溺れたり
悪いことをしたり もうもうよく思えない行為をしたりとかね
お金が入るとすぐそこに行くんですね
家に帰るんじゃなくて
パブに行くんでしょうに
お金があるんだからといって
それで結局人生は台無しになりますけどね
だからこれはもう絶対いかんということではなくて
そのその社会によって生き方が違いますからね
やっぱり家は大事ということは覚えておいて
罪を犯さないことを気をつけた方がいいんですね
それで仏教だからね 酒は飲まないと
これはもう人間バカになっちゃうんですね
どうなるかわからなくなっちゃうんですね
酒っていうのはえらい
もう何て言いますか 魔の薬で
麻薬といったらちょっと意味が違いますからね
で 魔が言われる通りに何でもやるようになってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから これはもう酒はやめた方がいいし
まあそれはまあ 大人になってからのからの話で
それからこのもう 例えばもう若さもどんどんいってしまうでしょうね
例えば三十五ぐらいになってくると
まあ四十ぐらい近寄ってくると
もう徹底した大人でしょうに
もう責任持ってる時代でしょうに
その時はすごく謙虚であること
威張らないことですね
ものすごく謙虚であること
それから落ち着いていること
よく見えますね この四十代の人々
全然落ち着いてない すごくストレスかかっちゃうんですね
それに だから一番バリバリ仕事をすると時になってくると
いつでも謙虚で それからいつでも落ち着いていることを習う
次に大事な言葉 サントゥッティという言葉があります
それはこの自分が得たもので十分満足する
いわゆるキリがなく 欲を抱いてはいけません
もう自分の将来が見えているんだからね
この会社だったら まあ係長まででもやっとやとわかったら
まあそこら辺で覚悟を決めてきた
課長まではとにかくと思ったら
まあもうクビになるかもしれません
課長になるどころか リストラの時代だから
そうすると人生が楽しめなくなっちゃうんですね
もう自分の能力も知られてるでしょ
４０飛んじゃうと ４０になってくると
それでまあ私の人生に能力はここら辺だよと思って
この満足する性格 それはサントゥッティと書くんだけど
直訳は喜びなんですね
喜びを感じなさいよということなんです
それであのもう家を作れるぐらい収入ないんだったら
それでもバカでかい家のこと
家を作りたい 作りたいとかね
えらいもう欲出しちゃうと喜びないんですね
生きることは 一生アパート暮らしでも
まあ自分の能力はもう知られたところで
それは喜べばいいんです
ですから 喜びを感じなさいということ
で 次に あの  これはお釈迦様の話だから
時期を見てちゃんと法を聞きなさいと
仏教を勉強しなさいということなんです
仏教というのは 世の中のすべての真理をまとめて教えているんですね
生命って何なのか 何のために生きているんですか？何をするべきかとかね
心の働きとか ありったけのことを全部教えているんですから
人間バカで死んでほしくないんですね
今まではお釈迦様は仕事に必要なことだけ教えたんです
ここでもう仕事も安定してあって
そろそろ退職するんであるじじいだからね
じゃあもう真理にチャレンジしなさいと
ですから 法を聞くこと入ってるんですね
それからタポーチャブラフマチャリアンチャ
例えばもう人が例えば仕事を終わった
まあ六十五 七十歳にもなりましたとする
それでもパッばっかしに飲み屋さんばっかし歩き回ったり
若い娘さんの体触ったりいじったりとかね
そればっかしやっちゃうと全くみっともない人間でしょうね
家の奥さんがもう年だから
もうババアだからといって
いろいろ若い女の子がもう人を騙して酒を売っているところにいて
そこで遊んだりすると
もう最悪状態になるんですね
人生は不幸に もうものすごく不幸になるんです
そこでお釈迦様が言うのは
まあ一旦年取ってきたら
まあ欲を捨てて もうタポー修行でもちょっとちょっとやってみる
ブラフマチャリアっていうのはもう欲をやめることなんですね
異性に対する欲をね もうやめる
もう関係ないと綺麗に頭からそこら辺消しておく
まあ大体この医学的なこと言って
まあ男だったら八十歳になっても九十歳になっても
もうもういくらでも異性との関係モテるそうとか何とか言うんだけど
そんな変な屁理屈で やっぱり年取ってくれば
もう体力っていうのは守った方がいいんですね
だから 性的なことに絞る体力は
自分の健康のために ボケないために
トラブルを起こさないために使った方がいいんですね
女の子と女の子もやっぱり恐ろしいことで
このおじいちゃんにお金あるんだなとわかったら
もうものすごく褒めるんですね
やっぱり私は若い人は嫌いだとかね
愛すら とかね おじいちゃんの方がすごく大好きですよとか
だから結婚しようと 今度財産狙っちゃうんですね
で 結婚しちゃったら早く殺しちゃうし
そういうのは世の中で大体はあるんですからね
やっぱり年取ってくると欲をやめた方が自分のためになるということ
それからお釈迦様がおっしゃったこの存在の真理があるんです
空住滅道という その真理を体験できるように頑張ってみなさいと
仕事はあるんです 例えば
異性との遊ぶことをやめたんだからといって
つまらないわけじゃないんです
すごい仕事はあるんです
真理を発見するために頑張ってくださいと
それからニッバーナサッチキリアーチ
涅槃を体験しなさいと
解脱を体験しなさいと
それは在家の方々にもできます
こちら出家しなさいと書いてないんです
涅槃というのは心の安らぎだから
もう空住滅道というお釈迦様の真理を発見して
滅という涅槃ですね それは自分の心でも体験できるように頑張ってみる
もし自分が正しい子供育てならば
子供は自分の面倒を見てくれる
ご飯ぐらいは作ってくれる
それで自分がもう真理に目指して頑張っちゃえば
それで涅槃さえも獲得できると
それでもうすべて終わりですよ
プログラムは人生の だからお釈迦様の育児っていうのは
この子供育てだけじゃなくて
死ぬまでのプログラム
死ぬ時は涅槃まで 解脱まで自分のものにして死ぬ
それ人生はすべて成功したことになります
それで次にお釈迦様はこのどうやって自分が一人前の立派な人間になったかと
あなた知ってますかと
その問題が出てきますね
その問題 次に答えるんですね
プッタッサローカダンミーチッタンヤッサナカンパティ
もし世の中で損があるわ
得があるわ 家も火事になるわ
時々すごい儲かったりするわ
いろんなことあるでしょうに
家の連中は病気になっちゃうわ
時々すごい元気になって行動するしね
批判されつつ 褒め褒められるし
世の中っていうのは波が多い
落ち着いてる自分が世の中のどんな波が起きても
自分には落ち着いていられるならば
まああまり気にしないという状態でいられるならば
悲しみが心にないならば
何も悲しいことはない
心配することなんもない
もう時々経済状態悪くなったって
まあまあ そんな世の中だからといって落ち着いている
自分の子供たち 孫たちはバンバン儲かるようになっちゃったら
まあ今はなんか経済状態いいみたいですよって
あんまりそこでもって喜んで舞い上がったりもしないという
落ち着いていられるならばということ
それで阿僧祇感 困ること
悩むこと何もない ヴィラジャン
もう心にあまり欲もない
これやりたい あれやりたいと欲もない
それからすごく安定感がある
ケイマン 平和がある 心の中で
それはもう人間が成功した証拠なんです
あ この人はもう人生は成功しているんだと
年取ったところで あんまり世の中のことを気にしないで落ち着いている
そこでお釈迦様は最後に結論するんですね
エータディサーニカトゥワーナ
あなた方はこのように生きているんだったら
サッバッタマッパラージタ
どこででも負けませんと
どんなことにおいても勝利者になるんだと
サッバッタソッティンガッチャンって
人生のいかなるところにおいても成功するんだと
これこそ生きる道だよと
という風にお釈迦さんはその経典進めちゃうんですね
だから仏教の育児方法っていうのは
そういうかなりスケールの大きい死ぬまでの教育なんです
そこで話は終了したいんですが
またいっぱい情報は持ってますけど
親に対して  6つのことを考えなくてはいけないんですね
1番目は親に育て育てられたので親を養います
1 これ子供の責任 親はもう年取っちゃったんだから
親の仕事をやら 親がやらなくちゃいけないことを自分がバトンタッチしてやってあげますと
2番目 そこで親の家柄
親の家の習慣 しきたり
そういうものはやっぱり子供が続けてほしいという希望が親にあるんですね
ですから 自分の家のしきたり
習慣やら そういうものを守って守ってあげますと
それから もし親に財産があって
自分にその財産が自分のものになったならば
それは親も安心できるように
親も喜べるように ちゃんと財産を無駄
無駄にしないで ちゃんと財産を管理して商売もするんだと
だから 親からもらった財産はもっとよくしっかりするようにしてあげるという責任
それから親が死んでから親に供養してあげたと
それは子供の責任 六つです
それで親の責任はまた六つあります
まず道徳を教えること
パパニワレンって書いてますけど
罪から罪を犯さないような人間にしてあげる
何があっても悪いことだけはできない人間に育ててあげること
それから いつでも良いこと
人を助けてあげることやら
人に親切にしてあげることやら
そうやって善行為をできる人間にしてあげる
3番目 シッパンシッカーペンティ教育させる
見てください この順番
お釈迦様は最初に人間育てること
教育は 3番目に来るんです
それで 4番目は まあ子供にふさわしい相手を見つけてあげてくださいということ
これはまあ 今の時代ではあまり関係ないかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり自分の子供の性格
生き方は自分 親は一番よく知ってますね
それで親同士で話し合って
まあふさわしい人を選んであげるんだったら
やっぱり大変いいことですけど
やっぱり今の時代からこれ計算して言うならば
やっぱり親にも納得できる相手と結婚した方がいいということなんですね
親はあまり反対しない人と結婚した方がすごくうまくいくんですね
それはできた親の場合です
できてない親の反対はあまり当てになりませんだからね
もし仏教的に子供を育てたい親だったら
もう親が賛成する人と結婚した方がぴったし合うんです
自分で選んでも 親に聞いてみたら
この人どうですかと それはまあ5番目
6番目 自分の財産を商売でも店でも会社でも
自分のものあるならば
もう息子にはい どうぞやってくださいと
で 自分が引退する その 6つは親の役目で
前の 6つは子供の役目で
まあそういう風にやってくださいというのは
また一つのお釈迦様の教えなんです
そこで  それで話は終わります
それからちょっとちょっとした遊びでもう一つ言います
お釈迦様に息子がいたんですよ
でもお釈迦様はこの息子を出家させたんですね
出家させたんだから これ息子は王子様でしたから
出家でえらい苦労をしただろうと思います
食べるものもなくて 面倒を見る家来もなくて
7歳でしたから 家来もいないし
美味しいものを食べて食べることもできないし
お世話は一人一人も誰もいない
その時自分の息子をね
やっぱりそれを出家させて
でお釈迦様はやっぱりお釈迦様だから
自分の子供は特別扱いしちゃうと
これまた他の人間にとっては良くないんですね
みんなの面倒見るんだから
お釈迦様 みんなの父親でしたから
だから我が子なんですけど
特別扱いすることもできない
サンガの一員として育てたんだから
そこでよくわかるんですね
お釈迦様が自分の我が子ということではなくて
あなたはもう出家したんだ
だから このサンガという大きなコミュニティの一員だけですよと
特別扱いないんだと その態度でお釈迦様はやっぱり息子のことを心配するんですね
それが親の仕事 息子が一人として頑張れるかと
特別扱いなし 一人として頑張ってくれるんだったら
お釈迦様も安心だということで
ある日自分の息子に会ったんです
こそこそと 公では会わないんです
そこでお釈迦様と息子のラーフラ尊者の間で対話があったんですね
それはどれほど美しいお釈迦様の言葉かというと
私は何回読んでも涙が来るんです
それぐらいすごい もう美しい父親のあるべき姿と息子のあるべき姿が見える芸なんですね
残念ながら皆様にはパーリ語はわかりませんので
その味は味わえないと思いますけどね
こんな大人になっている私はもうもう何を見たって読んでも全然感動しない
とんでもないつまらない人間なんですけど
この経典のこれ読むとやっぱり
感動するんですね お釈迦様はラーフル尊者にこう聞くんですね
カッチアビンナサンワーサナワジャーナシパンディタン
ウッカーダーローヒマヌッサーナンカッチアパチトータヤ
君どうですか？と ずっと仲良く付き合っているんだからと思って
賢者のことを馬鹿にすることでもしますかと
賢者っていうのは目上の人々ですね
ずっと一緒にいるんだからといって
目上の人々のことを馬鹿にすることでもしますか？と
軽視することでもしますかと
ウッカーダーローヒマヌッサーナンカッチアパチトータヤ
人間にあの灯火を持っている人を尊敬していますかと
いわゆる人間 人類に知恵の灯
知恵の光ように見せている方をあなた尊敬していますか？と
それは誰のことかというと
お釈迦様は自分の子供にはやっぱり良い環境を作ってあげなくちゃいけないんだと
良いお友達を作ってあげなくちゃいけないと思って
知恵の第一人者であったサーリプッタ尊者に任せたんです
この子供のことをよろしくお願いしますと
それっきりお釈迦様は面倒見なかったんです
だからやっぱり父親なんですよ
子供に教育させるために人を選ぶ場合は
もう人類の知恵の第一人者は自分の弟子だから
その人に任せたんですね
サーリプッタ先代っていうのは
もう尊者っていうのはもう人間の中の人間で
頭はものすごく良かったんだけど
すっごい謙虚な方なんですね
だから子供っていうのは
ちょっとからかったり
馬鹿にしたりする可能性はいくらでもあります
だからまあ 私も時々そういう問題あるんだけど
やっぱり若者とか子供と付き合っている場合は
いつでもガリガリで頑固でできませんし
いつでも知恵ばっかり見せびらかしちゃうと
子供にはやりきれないんですよ
だからたまたま何か言うんだけど
それからみんなと一緒にふざけて遊んだりする
それで時々子供は勘違いするんですね
自分と同じ仲間やと 勘違いして
もうこちらは大事な仕事をしている時でも走ってきて
一緒に遊ぼう遊ぼうとかね
それはちょっと困っちゃうんですね
もう説法をしている時でも来て
手を引っ張ったりとかしたりする場合もあったんだから
やっぱり子供っていうのはそういう性格もありますから
しょうがないんだけど
お釈迦様はそこは気をつけるんですね
あなたは人類に灯火を持っている人をちゃんと尊敬していますかと
そこでサーリプッタラーフル尊者がそう答えるんですね
ナハンアビンナサンワーサアワジャーナニパンディタ
長い間一緒に生活するんだからといって
私は目上の人は決して貶すこと
軽視することを決してしませんと
ウッカーダーローヒマヌッサーナンニッチャンアパチトーマヤ
人類に知恵の灯火を持っている人は
私は永遠に尊敬しているんだと
その行だけ覚えておいて
それはすごい この仏教の中であるすごい立派な言葉なんです
ウッカーダーロマヌッサーナ
この行なんですけど ウッカーダーロっていうのは
この光を持っている人
マヌッサーナ 人類に灯火ですね
人類に灯火を持ってる人
ニッチャン 常にいつでもアパチと私は尊敬しています
マヤ 私はですね で 英語では I always respect the torchbearer of mankind for you.
それすっごい立派な言葉なんです
我々は誰を尊敬するべきかというと
人類に知恵の光を与えている人々を永遠に尊敬するべきですね
申し訳ないですけど もう一回ゆっくりちょっと説明
ウッカーダーロマヌッサーナンニッチャンアパチトマヤ
誰かカタカナで書いていただけませんか
あの灯火を持つ人類の灯火を持つ人が
私に常に尊敬されていますというふうにはちゃんとした直訳なんです
パッシブボイスで言ってるんです
それもものすごい相手のことを尊敬すると
日本でもこの受動詞使ってますね
パーリ語でも同じことで
ですから 私はあの人のことを尊敬してませんってことじゃなくて
私に尊敬されてますと
もっと敬語なんです まあ一応仏教の育児論というのはもうちょっとスケール大きいんだから
ちょっと把握できなかったかもしれませんだけど
とにかくわかっているところで頑張ってください
どうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございました